wow
oh
so great
um
thank you
yes
yes
thank you
great
okay
you traveling
great job
yes
[Music]
my [ __ ]
mistakes
this year
um
oh
do you like it
um
yes
okay
where's the other guys
oh
um
oh
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
hello
nice
there you go
oh
that is
uh
should be good
[Music]
um
actually
[Music]
oh
okay
i think yes
[Music]
right
thank you
[Music]
yes
peace
[Music]
yes
[Music]
please
good
see
yes
[Music]
um
uh
[Music]
is
like
[Music]
yes
is
um
policemen
um
[Music]
kids
okay
it was
it was
kids
you
[Music]
exactly
thank you
okay
me
i know
so
stay
us
like
wrestling
yes
okay
oh
lucky
[Music]
hmm
is
foreign
yes
thank you
uh
so
foreign
okay
okay
oh
oh
um
all right
yes
there it
is yeah
yes
three
uh
right
it's
okay
yes
um
welcome back judge
as you can see things
get off the rails here when they decide
they have a floor boat we'll do our best
to
stick with the program and finish this
is a
proper way
the next stop is senator cruz of texas
thank you mr chairman judge good
afternoon good afternoon senator
under article 3 of the constitution
federal courts have jurisdiction
over only cases and controversies
uh which means under the constitution it
has to be an actual dispute that federal
courts cannot simply
issue advisory opinions on on a question
they may have a view on and one
component of article 3 jurisdiction is
the requirement of standing that in
order for a plaintiff to have standing
to bring a case
that that plaintiff at least generally
speaking must have a real and concrete
injuries is is that right
that is correct
um
so for example uh that that means that
that
even if i might have a disagreement with
some particular policy or some
particular law that that i can't bring a
case unless i am personally aggrieved by
that policy or that law
uh so for example your and my alma mater
harvard
uh is currently being sued for its
explicit and in my view egregious policy
of discriminating against asian
americans
even though i think that policy is
egregious
i as an individual plaintiff could not
bring a lawsuit challenging it because i
am not asian american is that right
if you brought a lawsuit
the court would have to evaluate whether
you had an actual injury in order to be
able to determine whether it had subject
matter jurisdiction to hear the suit but
but if i'm not in the class being
discriminated against then i don't have
the ability to bring the lawsuit is that
right
i think you'd have to have an actual
injury certainly people i think who are
in the class could claim that they had
an injury for that purpose
so now you're you're on the board of
overseers of harvard if you're confirmed
do you intend to recuse from this
lawsuit that is my plan senator okay
we discussed yesterday how the standard
for race discrimination was strict
scrutiny
uh the court has laid out a a different
standard for gender
discrimination
what is the constitutional standard that
applies to gender discrimination
gender discrimination the court has held
intermediate scrutiny applies which is
um
that the government has to have uh an
important interest
and um
the tailoring doesn't have to be as
narrow right
so yesterday uh under under questioning
from senator blackburn
uh you told her that that you couldn't
define
what a woman is
uh that you were not a biologist which
which i think you're the the only
supreme court nominee in history who's
been unable to answer
the question what is a woman
let me ask you as a
judge
how would you determine if a plaintiff
had
article 3 standing
to challenge a gender-based rule
regulation policy
uh without being able to determine what
a woman was
so senator i know that i'm a woman i
know that um senator blackburn is a
woman and the woman who i um admire most
in the world is in the room today my
mother
um it sounded as though well but the
question
let me ask under the modern leftist
sensibilities if
if
i decide right now that that i'm a woman
um
then
apparently i'm a woman does that mean
that i would have article 3 standing to
challenge a gender-based restriction
senator to the extent that you are
asking me about um
who has the ability to bring lawsuits
based on gender those kinds of issues
are working their way through the courts
and i'm not able to comment on them okay
if if i can
change my gender if i can be a woman and
then an hour later if i decide i'm not a
woman anymore i guess i would lose
article 3 standing
tell me does that same principle apply
to other protected characteristics for
example i'm i'm an hispanic man could
could i decide i was an asian man would
i have the ability to be an asian man
and challenge harvard's discrimination
because i made that decision
senator i'm not able to answer your
question you're asking me about
hypotheticals and um
how you would assess standing if i if i
came in and said i have decided i
identify as an asian man i would assess
standing the way i assess other legal
issues which is to listen to the
arguments made by the parties consider
the relevant precedents
and
constitutional principles involved and
make a determination
okay let's
go back to your favorite topic of this
hearing
which is the criminal law cases you had
as a district judge and in particular
the cases involving child pornography
now your defenders both on the
democratic side of the diocese and also
in the press
have suggested that that the criticism
that has been raised uh has been somehow
cherry-picked that it's only some
specific examples so so i'm going to
give you an opportunity
to discuss each and every case you've
had
because looking at your cases and i've
now examined all of the child porn cases
you've had as a federal district judge
there is a very consistent pattern
so let's start and by the way i'm
excluding the cases so senator durbin
and senator coons focused on
the nickerson case the fife case the
nguyen case in the hilly case i'm
excluding those because those are not
child porn cases those are actual
sexual assault of a child which is
markedly different and i will concede
when you're dealing with sexual assault
you have been willing to impose stricter
penalties so let's focus on actual child
pornography cases
and let's go through each of them
because if it's right that we're
cherry-picking then you should be able
to to explain quite powerfully
now your justification is that you're
following the statute and as you know 18
usc section
3553
lays out the factors that that as a
district judge
you had to consider in sentencing and
let's start with the hess case united
states versus hess
now in that case a man sent six pictures
a pre of a prepubescent girl that he
claimed was his daughter to an
undercover law enforcement officer
officers found over 600 images
of child pornography
including images of sexual acts being
performed on pre-pubescent children the
defendant pled guilty and i believe in
all of these cases the defendant pled
guilty so there's no question about
guilt they came in and pled guilty in
your courtroom
the charge carried a mandatory minimum
sentence of five years and a mandatory
maximum sentence of 20 years
the sentencing guidelines recommended
151 to 188 months sentence
the government as part of a plea a deal
agreed to argue for 60 months but didn't
agree that that would be the sentence
simply that they would advocate it
and you in turn
sentenced hess to
60 months so
under the terms of the statute why did
you choose to sentence hess to the
absolute lowest possible sentence you
were allowed to sentence under law
thank you senator i have
spoken at length throughout this hearing
about these cases i've said
what i'm going to say which is
i've taken every case seriously these
are
very
horrible asking you specifically about
test case
i've taken every case seriously so
you're not going to answer that
these are very horrible crimes as was
that one and as a mother
having to look at these pictures having
to follow
congress's directive having to listen to
recommendations like the government in
that case which
argued for 60 months
i
imposed the sentence that i believed
was the sentence
that was required by law so i believe
you and i've actually i've read your
sentencing hearing in each one of these
cases for which we have transcripts and
there's several of which we don't have
transcripts
so in each of these cases you read from
the same script so in each of these
cases you say that
the distribution of child pornography is
an extremely serious federal crime
and you point out that the crime
involves people who are taking pictures
and videos of real children while the
children are being sexually abused
uh in hess you pointed out that he had
hundreds hundreds of images of children
in sexually compromised position
some of them in ca engaged in
masochistic acts all of this i'm reading
from you at on the bench
and most importantly the children in
these
pictures are not knowing and willing
participants in the degrading conduct
that was being depicted they were being
forced forced by someone off screen to
commit unspeakable acts of sexual
violence for the pleasure of the people
filming them
and for the gratification of people
everywhere and what concerns me is that
many of those people have absolutely no
shred of empathy
for what that conduct does for the
children who were being abused in this
way and you read this script in every
one of these cases so you talk about
that these are terrible terrible crimes
um
but you also
and and in hess you said
i have to say that what i found
particularly disturbing about your
offense
was that quote you apparently concocted
a story about having photographed your
own daughter who you purportedly were
willing to take pictures of to trade
with other people
i know from your comments and from those
who know you that you are unlikely to
ever harm a child which i find
remarkable that you've got a child
predator in your court who says i'm
unlikely to harm a child and you say
well you told me that so so clearly
you're unlikely but you say
but in the context of the crime
you represented that you would
that in and of itself is astonishing so
you talk about it as astonishing
you nonetheless sentenced him to the
very lowest possible sentence allowed
under law and what's striking
is in these cases and half of them in
five
you sentence the defendant to the
absolute lowest sentence under law
let's look at another case let's look at
united states versus chasin
now chasing is a particularly
nasty case
in chasing the defendant was accused
accessed a dropbox that contained 35
videos and 13 partially downloaded files
of prepubescent
minor females engaging in sexually
explicit conduct
uh at least three of the instances of
prepubescent female children were
engaged in sexual activity with adult
men
the images included the sexual abuse of
children including those as young as
toddlers and several of these cases that
you had involved the sexual abuse of
toddlers which is truly horrifying
in this instance chasen pleaded guilty
the guidelines recommended a sentence of
78 to 97 months
the prosecution argued that should be
what the sentence was
and you sentenced chasen to just 28
months
why did you sentence someone who had
child pornography of toddlers being
sexually abused
to 28 months 64 below what the
prosecutors asked for
thank you senator
you've picked out
um i don't know seven eight cases i've
sentenced more than a hundred people but
not the child pornography
in every case senator i look at
the evidence i look at the
recommendations of not just the
government because my duty as a a judge
is to consider all of the arguments that
are made in a case
i look at the evidence
i talk to the defendants about
the harms that they have
uh uh engaged in
many of these defendants or people who
um okay judge with respect you're not
answering my question you're right you
talk to them about the harms let me read
you again from what you said at the
bench
you said in this instance
with mr chasen you said among the
defendants nationwide who received a
below guidelines sentence on the basis
of a downward variance as opposed to a
departure
the average sentences ranged from 84 to
92 months so that's what you lay out as
the average
our democratic colleagues say well
other federal judges sentenced below
the guidelines that is true a number of
federal judges do
our democratic colleagues have not
pointed to a single federal judge in the
country who 100 percent of the time
sentences
child porn defendants to markedly below
what the prosecution has recommended
unless you have a mandatory minimum and
no ability to do so in this case you say
comparable defendants are sentenced to
84 to 92 months
sentencing guidelines by statute require
you to have similarly situated
defendants sentenced to similar
sentences but you don't sentence chase
into 84 to 92 months you sentenced him
to 28 months why senator i've said what
i'm going to say about these cases no
one case
can stand in for a judge's entire record
okay but i'm discussing every week
so if you're not going to explain it
senator would you please let her respond
no not if she's not going to answer my
questions they're just going to give a
speech
and
you you are not taking my time if you
want a filibuster you're you're welcome
to do so but i would at least give you
an opportunity to speak and you should
give her an opportunity to respond if
she wants to answer the question i asked
her why she's allowed her to answer i
asked her why she sentenced chase into
28 months when comparable defendants in
her own words were sentenced to
substantially higher and she said she's
not going to answer did you i mean i
would welcome your answer senator i
didn't say i'm not going to answer okay
i said my answer is facts in this case
chasing why did you sentence into just
28 months senator you're looking at the
record i don't have the record here what
i will say
is that in every case
i looked at the recommendations of not
only the government but also the
probation office
the defendant
the record
the evidence i took into account the
seriousness of the offense
and by the way you know one of the
striking things in chasin the prosecutor
comes in front of you
and says this is the prosecutor's
argument at this point and the
prosecutor says
i understand from my experience before
your honor
your honors objection policy objections
to the to the 2g 2.2 sentencing
guidelines and he goes on to say however
in this case in particular the
four-point specific offense
characteristic
is justified because it contains
sato-masochistic
images
of infants
and toddlers
i'm trying to understand how you see
someone that possesses images of infants
and toddlers
being sexually violated and you sentence
them to 64
below what the prosecutor is asking for
you don't provide a justification
other than a generic concern that the
guidelines are too high you don't
provide a justification as required by
statute
so i'm asking you to take the
opportunity to explain to this committee
and the american people why in a hundred
percent of the cases
you have people with vile crimes and you
have language saying they're vile crimes
but then you sentence them
to very very low sentences and and why
do you consistently 100 of the time
choose to do that
senator no one case can stand in for a
judge's entire sentencing record i've
sentenced more than 100 people you have
eight or nine cases
in that chart okay judge you said that
before the these are the eight or nine
child porn cases i will say to correct
the record i'll just say to the judge
there's no point in responding he's
going to interrupt you thanks look i
appreciate the chairman trying to
filibuster if you don't like your
witnesses answers you're welcome to
provide your own
she is declining to answer the question
and and chairman durbin if you want to
join her on this on the on the bench you
can
but chairman durbin uh my job is to make
sure durbin i'm not interrupting your
questioning i'm asking you to give her a
chance to answer but she's consistently
said she's not going to answer i want to
clarify for the record by the way the
case i was discussing was cooper and not
chasing
uh but chasin
is
uh the case that i was reading from your
transcript was cooper but chasen all
right let's get to chase and i pulled
the wrong tab
chasin is equally horrifying and you say
in chase and there's something senator
graham asked you
so the guidelines lay out different
enhancements and and you say repeatedly
and this is true in all your cases you
say you disagree with the guidelines you
think they're wrong
and the two guidelines you disagree with
is one there's an enhancement for use of
a computer and you say the world has
changed now all of these are on a
computer and i understand that i don't
agree with you but i understand that
that is a
understandable thing to say but the
second thing you say over and over again
is there's an enhancement for the number
of images
and you say repeatedly for example in in
chasing you say whatever the state of
the law and technology at the time of
the guidelines were first adapted
neither the use of the computer
nor the number of images
are especially aggravating factors today
now i find that bizarre and you say it
in every case you say the number of
images it's not an aggravating factor it
doesn't matter and you won't apply the
enhancement
do you really believe that that a
predator that has hundreds or thousands
of images of hundreds or thousands of
children being sexually violated
has not committed an offense that that
is more serious than someone that has a
single picture of a single child a
single picture of a single child is
horrifying but hundreds of children that
have been violated do you really believe
that is not a more serious offense
senator i did not have any cases
involving hundreds of thousands of
pictures i said hundreds or thousands
you had you had cases involving hundreds
you had cases involving thousands you're
right you didn't have hundreds of
thousands
and i also applied an enhancement just
not to the degree of the guidelines
you're right it's a it's a five-point
enhancement under the guidelines you
provide two yes so not zero
suggestions
are you suggesting the number of images
doesn't matter because you say it in
court over and over again that the
number of images doesn't reflect that
it's a more serious crime do you really
believe that senator
as i said to
senator graham
the court is taking into account a
number of circumstances the commission
has done a report about the operation of
the guidelines which enhancements
actually reflect
uh different levels of culpability with
so let me let me ask you this judge
you've said the purpose of sentencing is
to distinguish and distinguish between
crimes that are not as serious
from from truly egregious crimes is is
that right no senator so what is the
purpose of sentencing if it's not to
distinguish from
less serious crimes from truly egregious
crimes it is to assign proportional
punishment it is to do justice in cases
where you have defendants who are
convicted of the same conduct but have
different differing levels of
culpability well i will point out
that you have a pattern it doesn't
matter how egregious the case is senator
hawley talked about the hawkins case
where you had an 18 year old with
pictures of boys as young as eight being
sexually assaulted and raped and you
sentenced him to just three months in
jail
and i will point out the stewart case
the last one on this list because we're
running out of time
the stewart case you describe
that he had over six thousand seven
hundred images and videos so that's a
lot six thousand seven hundred that's a
lot of kids being sexually assaulted
you have taken over a minute of my time
mr chairman exactly so
you've been given extra time you usually
ask for it you're giving it okay
i i know you want to interrupt i know
you don't like just trying to play by
the rules i i know you like to interrupt
but you consumed a substantial question
in my time of my questioning and i'm i'm
going to ask my questions and and you
can if you want to testify you're
welcome to senator judge you play with
the same rules
in the stewart case
you said from the bench
thus although this is not necessarily an
atypical case your child pornography
possession crime
was egregious in the court's view okay
so this is a bad one if you're actually
sentencing defendants you said this was
egregious what did you set in stuart for
the guidelines said 97 121 months
prosecutor said 97 months you said it's
egregious 6
700 images
you come in with 57. i'm as
57 expensive in the stewart case do you
want to address that because you're
claiming it's cherry-picking in fact
you're welcome to explain any of these
cases but let's take the stewart case
why coons did you sentence him for half
the amount you're not recognized senator
senator you don't want her to answer
that question you wouldn't allow her mr
chairman she may answer the question
i've asked her why she's sent in steward
i'm senator by two minutes why she said
because you've interrupted me for two
minutes mr chairman will you allow her
to answer the question or do you not
want the american people to hear why
with someone she described as an
egregious point senator where you get a
little bit chairman durbin will you
allow her to answer the question you
want to allow her name i i will happily
allow her to the question is
thank you senator stewart an egregious
child pornography possesses
half of the amount please requested by
the prosecutor please senator
will you allow her to answer the
question chairman durbin senator coons
why are you not allowing her to answer
the question there's not another senator
here who has not allowed her to answer
the question
i'm not asking another question but
allow her to answer the question
chairman durbin thank you chairman why
do you not want the american people to
know what happened in the stewart case
or any of these cases chairman durbin
i've never seen the chairman refuse to
allow a witness to answer a question
you can bang it as loud as you want i
can just tell you at some point you have
to follow the rules okay will you let
her answer the question you've you've
been interrupting and by the way with
senator graham it went 10 minutes over
you've taken a big chunk of the time
will you allow her to answer a question
you've given her why are you afraid of
her she's welcome to answer it right now
will you let her
senator coons will you let so no you
don't want her to answer the question
senator coombs will you let her answer
the question
chairman durbin
apparently we're very afraid of the
american people hearing the answer to
that question we here in the senate in
this committee today are in the middle
of a policy fight
it's my understanding that across this
nation
more than 70 percent of district court
judges who impose sentences in cases
such as the ones that have been so
vigorously debated here
depart downwards from the sentencing
guidelines from the requests of the
prosecutors and as you've explained
repeatedly and in detail that's because
a sentencing judge is required to weigh
a whole series of factors
how many opinions have you written as a
judge your honor
i've written at least 570 opinions
senator and in how many cases have you
imposed sentences
as a federal judge more than 100 cases
and across all of those we've just heard
very forcefully assertions made about
you and your character and your
capabilities your background narrowing
in on just a few
and i would simply put for those who are
watching and trying to understand what
all of this is about
um that in an attempt to distract from
your broad support your deep record your
outstanding intellectual and legal
credentials um that we are taking what
is a policy dispute that should be
decided by members of the senate
if we want to change the sentencing
guidelines to make them mandatory rather
than advisory if we want to change the
structure within which a federal judge
imposes sentences we could do that
but to demand that you be held
accountable for this practice that is
nationwide and is years old um i view as
an unfair misrepresentation of your
record
so if i could
let's go to something that you did as
the vice chair of the sentencing
commission um an important vote that you
took in 2014
because in my view it shows how
fundamentally misguided are the attacks
that try to characterize you as someone
who at all costs will do what you can to
help criminal defendants
let me just lay out the context for a
moment
in 2010 congress
enacting a policy choice unanimously
passed the fair sentencing act a bill
that reduced the disparity in sentences
between
crack cocaine and powdered cocaine from
101 to 18 to 1. and the sentencing
commission unanimously concluded this
law meant those currently in prison on
crack offenses could seek to shorten
their sentences
four years later the commission further
concluded that individuals who provided
substantial assistance to the government
people who cooperated who helped out the
prosecution could use this law to
shorten their sentence retroactively
beyond any break they might have gotten
for their cooperation
but you disagreed
in your public remarks at the time you
explained that although given your prior
service as a federal public defender it
might seem logical you'd support this
direction you could not do so
because you concluded it was manifestly
inconsistent with the law
and would create unfair disparities
between those previously sentenced
cooperators in those sentences today
essentially if i understand your view
it was that the sentence of a cooperator
shouldn't be understood to be based on
the sentencing ranges modified by the
fair sentencing act but was best
understood as a fixed discount of the
mandatory minimum that a fair sentencing
act had not changed i know this is
technical
but i just wanted to make sure i'm
characterizing this correctly before
reaching a conclusion
do i understand the context correctly in
which you made this decision
yes senator perfectly it was um
debate among the commission one of the
very few
in which we couldn't reach agreement uh
about
uh the retroactive application of the
fair sentencing act reduction and so
just to finish the framing
the sentencing commission which often
decides things unanimously was sharply
divided and here's who was on each side
you voted to deny relief to cooperators
to deny them a pathway towards reducing
their prison sentences and you were
joined by two conservatives well known
to us judge william pryor
and now judge dabney friedrich
and the three of you were outvoted
um by four commissioners which included
judge inohusa an individual nominated by
president reagan and described as a
hard-nosed no-nonsense judicial
conservative who was on the other side
of the argument from you
so you've got four commissioners
including an outstanding conservative
reagan nominee
and they thought the law could be
interpreted to give
a break on sentencing
and you were on the other side of that
argument
if as someone
has tried to paint you you simply were
determined to give every break you could
to criminal defendants all you had to do
was join the majority and this would
have passed but that's not what you did
um help me understand why
not thank you senator um as you say this
is a sort of technical kind of in the
weeds
discussion but the
top line is that
when i looked at the issues and i looked
at the law it was my opinion
that
the law did not provide for
the further reduction
that was being considered
across an incredibly broad range of
sentences you've had to impose in cases
on which you've had to opine um i'm
picking this one in part because it's
not getting any attention in this
confirmation process
but for folks who'd like some insight
into how you make decisions and how you
explain those decisions um there's a
video it's publicly available of your
april 2014 of the public meeting of the
sentencing commission where you laid out
your position so i encourage folks to
just watch that
and they'll see a jurist who understands
that her commitment above all
is to determine what the law requires
and then follow it
in my view that's an individual who
belongs on the supreme court
by the way your position that the law
required that there not be further
breaks given in this context ultimately
won the day
my colleague from new jersey made a
point of mentioning a relevant case
united states versus booker yesterday i
have to say that in this case it was
decided in coons versus united states
with a k not a c
look we all have our judicial record for
which we work
um
but the supreme court ruled for exactly
the same reasons you did in this
argument that was made public so i i
just think your honor this is an example
of you
looking hard at the law
making a tough decision
ultimately being vindicated in that
decision
but taking a position
that is not
the caricature that's been proffered by
some of you
yesterday i i ran through a number of
the the letters and statements um that
debunked some of the
attacks that have been levied based on a
handful of sentencing decisions there
was the national review piece by a
conservative former prosecutor who calls
out the smear on your sentencing
practices in cases involving child
pornography the statement by the
fraternal order of police and the
international association of chiefs of
police endorsing your even-handed and
judicious approach to the law the
glowing letter from 24 prominent
conservative attorneys and the
resounding recommendation we heard in
person from judge griffith
there's also been received here a letter
from a number of retired federal judges
including two republican nominees
rejecting this mischaracterization of
your sentencing record as i've said this
is a policy dispute that we should be
deciding not an appropriate basis on
which to mischaracterize your record or
your character we have letters from the
national coalition of domestic violence
in addition to these law enforcement
leaders from survivors advocates crime
victims the breadth of your support from
the very communities my colleagues have
suggested you're making less safe
shows just how off-base these attacks
are
and in my view as a testament to your
qualities and qualifications so
we all agree all of us
that it's critical to protect our
children and prevent the kinds of
heinous crimes we've heard
about in some detail earlier today it's
why i'm introducing a bipartisan
reauthorization
in terms of child abuse act something
that we could act on as a committee to
do our job which is set policy and pass
laws
but i also frankly think we need to be
mindful
that we are asking of you
to get engaged in that policy dispute in
front of this committee which is not the
role of a judge something you well
understand
let me turn if i could to another reason
i think you're deeply qualified and that
you will bring something important to
the supreme court
brian stevens one of america's leading
civil rights lawyers and
by happy coincidence at delaware native
um has spoken about how achieving
justice requires being proximate to the
people most impacted by the criminal
justice system and you've done that
as a public defender you've represented
individuals in the criminal justice
system
as a district court judge you have
looked individuals in the eye and told
them that for their crimes against
society they will spend years or decades
in prison
you have met with
fought for and advocated for victims
you've also studied the big picture
as an effective and engaged member of
the sentencing commission you've poured
over data reviewed thousands of letters
and thought hard about the appropriate
national approach to just punishment
in a more policy oriented role
you've also thought about the big
picture as a judge when considering the
precedent that your opinions set
i'd be interested briefly in how your
experience on the sentencing commission
shaped your approach as a district court
judge and how the interplay of all these
factors might shape or contribute to
your decisions as a supreme court
justice
thank you senator um
one of the things
district judges sentencing judges often
say
when asked about
the task is that
sentencing is the hardest thing
that a judge has to do and it's in part
for the reasons that you
have articulated that um it's one thing
to
understand the law to read it in a book
it's one thing to look at data and
numbers and
and make policy based on that it's quite
another
to have someone
in the courtroom whether as a victim of
crime or a defendant who's perpetrate
perpetrated a crime
and have to decide
how to proceed and pronounce
uh sentence on that
individual the work that i did on the
sentencing commission
which was prior to my becoming a
district judge
i think enabled me
to understand um
unwarranted sentencing disparity
to understand some of the
policy
reasons behind
the guidelines and to
make the kinds of evaluations that the
law now requires since the guidelines
are no longer mandatory and i feel felt
um
i felt
better in a sense about
the task of calculating the guidelines
which is what courts have to do at the
beginning of a sentence they can be a
little complex
and having been on the sentencing
commission i think that helped and some
of these cases do make their way
uh to the supreme court so
um
so i think that i am prepared uh to
handle
um the cases that involve
sentencing um that that do go to the
court in preparing for this confirmation
i went back and read a lecture you gave
but it was later published in the
harvard law review
um about the balance the challenge of
sentencing about that moment i i had the
joy the blessing of clerking for a judge
on the third circuit um i
my legal skills and talents did not
allow me the opportunity to clerk for
the supreme court as you did but and
also the district court and also the
circuit court uh but i clerked for a
judge who i first met when she was a
district court judge and imposing a
sentence on on someone who was a crack
dealer and she did a remarkable job of
speaking to the victims speaking to the
community speaking to the prosecutor and
the defense attorney and then speaking
directly to the defendant in imposing a
very long sentence um and as i got to
know her later i recognized that you
know as a member of our community and as
someone who saw the importance of that
moment that public moment of helping the
defendant understand what they'd done so
that they might somehow change but also
helping the victims understand what had
happened that she took that very
seriously incredibly seriously
in the harvard law review publication of
your remarks you said that you're
persuaded by the theories of punishment
that accept all human beings are
responsible moral agents and you view
punishment as a necessary consequence of
the defendant's decision to engage in
criminal behavior
you also went on to say that the
challenge is balancing the
acknowledgement all of us are more than
just the worst thing we've ever done
that there is a need to ensure the
defendant is adequately addressed and
punished
what i think you say in that lecture
what you've shown across the arc of your
public service
reveals someone who understands the
appropriate need for punishment in our
society but who is also striving to
follow the balance of recommendations
guidelines statute and the context and
facts
and i trust that as
members of this committee and the senate
as a whole and the general public
take the time which they should do
to give a fair reading to the whole
scope and arc and reach of your service
that they'll see you as someone
who cares deeply about our constitution
and the rights that make us free as you
said in your opening statement
um your career in the law your service
on the bench your thoughtful responses
to questions put to you the way you've
maintained your composure all impress me
as i mentioned
i don't think labels
such as a judicial philosophy are always
that meaningful or dispositive
i think in your case a deep admiration
for the constitution and an
understanding that the role of a judge
is a limited one
are critical
and qualifying
you opened yesterday by referencing how
your parents
were educated in racially segregated
schools in florida but how you
just one generation later
were raised in integrated schools and
had far greater opportunities to put
your evident god-given talents to work
and service to our nation
you cited this one generation change as
an example of the greatness of america
of course the supreme court played a
central role
in more correctly interpreting the
constitution and applying it in a manner
that allowed this reversal of unjust law
to occur
i think the experiences of your own
family and your connection to the
experiences of trailblazers who came
before you on whose shoulders you stand
has meaningfully shaped what kind of a
justice you will be
i think you know in your bones how
important our constitution and the rule
of law is and i think as someone who
served on the sentencing commission a
public defender and the trial court
appellate court judge
you have the ability to see across the
whole scope and reach of how the law
impacts families communities and our
nation
last in some ways i think um most
importantly i've learned that as a
person and a judge you have humility
judge griffith who came before this
committee to introduce you and scores of
others we've heard from i've just
referenced have lauded your practice of
judicial restraint and you've said a
core component of your philosophies your
understanding that the judge's role is a
limited one
well i think restraint is a core part of
your approach to decision making partly
because
you are a judge who is humble enough to
know that the constitution and the laws
passed by congress say what the law is
the judge has a limited role in deciding
questions of law based on facts
presented
penn law professor lisa fairfax your
other introducer your dear friend
explained that since college at harvard
and then through law school you've been
a mentor and a role model she praised
her warmth and intelligence your
devotion to friends and family but she
also mentioned your humility
she knew you were honored and humbled by
the significance of this moment not what
it means for you but what it means for
our nation
i remember thinking about this on monday
and i had a chance to talk to your
brother kitaj um and he mentioned that
he knew you were destined for this
moment your whole life
um i am sure he would say you've been
exceptional since you were student body
president at palmetto high school
i suspect your wonderful family
upbringing is partly responsible for
this facet of your character
i suspect your faith has played a role
in sustaining you as mine does and so
does many others in this room i've often
found instruction and comfort
in the verse what does the lord require
of you but to do justice
love mercy
and walk humbly with your god
i'm not going to ask you to reflect on
that verse your honor but i i wouldn't
be surprised if it's one of your
favorites that sustains you
um let me close by returning to what
judge griffith said
uh when he told us in his heartfelt
introduction of you on monday
and something you've also shown in the
uh hours uh you've been grilled by this
body
um he had already written a letter to
this uh committee delivering his
endorsement he took the extra step to
then amplify it in person
and he did so because of confidence in
you and because he was delivering a
message to us as a committee
that supreme court confirmations should
be more than just exercises and partisan
tribalism
he said there should be nothing unusual
about a judge who just happened to be
appointed by a republican president and
who holds conservative legal views
coming forward to support a nominee
with your impeccable qualifications and
character
especially a nominee whose legal
opinions whose actions and decisions as
a judge he was in a position to review
for years
given that you were a district court
judge and he was a circuit court judge
look our confirmation hearings for
justices have sadly been devolving over
many years
into longer and longer exercises of
partisan politics punctuated by just
brief glimpses and occasional thoughtful
examinations of a nominee's judicial
decision-making and views on the
constitution which should properly be
our main focus
i have to believe this sad state of
affairs troubles my colleagues of both
sides and all who watch this
but as i reflect on these hearings i'm
hopeful that your
um gracious thoughtful
exchanges with some members
will be remembered as just one more
service you've rendered to our nation
and i hope some watching these hearings
will be reminded um that even though we
disagree with the policy preferences
or opinions of a nominee we should all
recognize when a nominee is
fundamentally qualified
deeply committed to the constitutional
rule of law and a person of great
character
judge griffith reminded us at the outset
of this week and i quote
as justice scalia taught us
for so long an indispensable feature of
the republic the constitution created
is an independent judiciary of judges
who've taken an oath not to a president
or party
but to the american people and to god
that they will be
impartial
i couldn't agree with more with judge
griffith you have demonstrated your
unwavering commitment to that oath and
your impartiality your abundant
qualifications it'll be my honor to
support your confirmation for associate
justice
with that mr chair i yield
thank you senator coons the senator from
nebraska senator says thanks chairman
durbin um
judge welcome back uh i'd like to
associate myself with parts of what
chris said there in his closing um i
would differ with him about uh
whether or not getting to precision on
judicial philosophy matters but you know
that you know i've been wrestling about
it for a couple of weeks um but i'd like
to affirm chris's point about the beauty
of the hymn to america you told and
through the eyes of your parents and
the changes um the the growth uh in the
country over the course of the last two
generations and the wall street journal
had an editorial this morning that said
pretty much the same thing as chris just
said which is that the the hymn to
america that you gave in your opening on
monday afternoon and some of your
comments yesterday were inspiring and
beautiful so i associate myself with
senator coons on that um i'd like to
talk a little bit about your time as a
judge and particularly how you see
development and and growth and change
over that time so take us back nine
years and then maybe five years ago and
then today how is your approach uh to
being a judge changed from year one to
year five to today
thank you senator um
i do think there was a little bit of
growth i hope there was a little bit of
growth
certainly in year one and year five i
was still a district judge in both of
those years differ dramatically from my
work
as an appellate judge which is where i'm
currently stationed
in every job in year one you're new
you're trying to figure things out i
don't know that i had quite pinned down
at the very beginning uh exactly how i
would approach
uh cases but by the time i got to year
five i think i had a really good sense
of this
judging thing
and was able
um to
demonstrate in my opinions the
many many opinions that i've written
the way in which i go about
making my decisions
i was able to demonstrate
clearly i think
that
the particular parties
in the case the issues in the case what
it's about
uh from a standpoint of personal
preference is not an issue i'm setting
those things aside i am
ruling from a position of neutrality and
trying
to determine
in every case what the law requires
i am looking at
only the facts and the law in the case
i'm evaluating the arguments of the
parties and
if it's statutory interpretation i'm
trying to ascertain what congress has
intended
i
am committed
i think my record shows
to the understanding that that is the
role and the only appropriate role
for a judge
um i'd like to talk a little bit about
the troubling pattern we see on law
school campuses and across higher
education more broadly especially in the
last five years
there's obviously a trend toward
shouting down and canceling opinions
that are outside the left-leaning
mainstream
calls for firing professors canceling
professors
shouting down and sometimes threatening
speakers who bring
divergent diverse opinions
calls to discipline fellow students
these tactics are increasingly
commonplace
particularly against conservative
speakers and professors and students but
also
increasingly against traditional
liberals i'm a former college president
and one of the sort of oddities uh that
doesn't fit inside the tribalism of how
a lot of times media covers things in dc
one of the oddities for me is how often
i have liberal professors reaching out
to me
saying that their experience on campus
is becoming much less interesting
that the divide on american political
campuses is less and less
uh conservative policy leaning versus
liberal or progressive policy leaning
but more and more liberal versus
illiberal um and
i think these campaigns are obviously
deeply problematic they shut down debate
rather than teaching students how to
engage ideas that they might not have
encountered before which is also a
pretty decent definition of education
if you already knew everything before
you ever encountered a new idea you
wouldn't need to write checks or take
time off of
productive life so
there's obviously a tendency and
response for students to self-censor
rather than learn from each other and
this robs students of the chance to
engage with ideas from across the
political spectrum but in particular in
law schools
it robs students of the opportunity to
learn how to consider an alternate
position and argue a different uh point
of view than they might have had so
given that you're a debate champion in
earlier days as well i'd like to ask if
you agree that law students should be
engaging with ideas from across the
political spectrum even those they
disagree with rather than trying to shun
those different ideas
thank you senator um
let me just say uh in part because these
issues are things that could implicate
matters that come before the courts i
will just say that as a general matter
[Music]
law school like
many schools is a place where
ideas and perspectives are considered
and in the law
as i've said
it's important for the judge who's
making the decision to have
different
arguments
and so one of the things that
traditionally happens in law schools is
that
you are trained
in law
to
make arguments that are at times not
even the arguments that you personally
agree with because the understanding
is that in litigation in disputes that
come before the court the court is going
to want to hear from
different viewpoints uh so in that sense
the the essence of legal instruction is
to have
different arguments being made because
that models in great
part
what happens in a courtroom
i'm i really am not trying to ask any
kind of gotcha question here i suspect
we highly agree so i don't understand
the qualification you put at the
beginning there's no sort of second
order fork on my question it is better
to debate ideas that you disagree with
and shout them down isn't it
it is better in law schools to make sure
that there are ideas from all
perspectives and in order to have that
happen they can't be suppressed so you
don't want students shouting down other
students or visiting professors right i
mean i i'm honestly i didn't think there
was any chance we would differ on this
so i'm not no i'm not i'm not suggesting
you're against cancelling people i
assume i i'm not i'm not suggesting that
we differ what i'm what i'm saying is
that um these issues about uh speech on
campus and the like or the kinds of
things that are issues that are working
their way
you know in different formats and
different ways through the courts and so
i'm just being careful in terms of my my
answers okay i'm i'm i'm trying to lead
you because i want to because i think
american civic health will be better off
you're going to be a hero you are
already a hero to lots and lots of kids
students maybe some bound for the law
but more broadly students across the
country and i think it's in america's
public interest for them to hear you as
an advocate for the full vigorous strong
kid debate of different views and so i i
suspect you are an advocate for vigorous
and robust debate i don't see how you
might be constrained against saying that
because of future cases but um i'm gonna
just assume we're mostly aligned on this
i i think that's a fair assumption thank
you um i do want to make uh before i
move on just because we've had um
a number of members of this committee
comment on cameras in the court um i've
made my position on this clear a lot of
times but if if i can
give a tiny bit of um
friend of the court brief in advance
because i think it when you're on the
court and you all continue to debate
this issue
i think it should be a decision for the
supreme court to make about whether or
not there are cameras in the courtroom
not a decision for the article one
branch to make for article three
but i think it's incredibly important
for us to recognize because i think i
differ from a lot of my colleagues on
this who are advocates for cameras in
the courtroom i get their position
that transparency is a virtue
transparency is a good thing i also
believe that pen and pad
can facilitate a whole heck of a lot of
transparency just fine and it's healthy
for americans to recognize the second
and third and fourth order effects of
cameras a huge part of why this
institution doesn't work well is because
we have cameras everywhere
cameras change human behavior we know
this you don't have the same kinds of
conversation over the dinner table with
your family when you're wrestling
through issues and apologizing for
something and saying i said this before
but maybe i should modify what i said i
was my tone was jerky my substance
didn't account for your position
there's a whole bunch of things that
humans can do if they're not immediately
mindful of some distant camera audience
that they might be trying to create a
sound bite for
and uh instagram can be useful for some
small things but for intellectual
discourse it is not a friend um and i
think we should recognize that the
jackassery we often see around here
is partly because of people mugging for
short-term
camera opportunities and it is
definitely um a second and third and
fourth order effect that the court
should think through
before it has advocates in there who are
not only trying to persuade u9 justices
um but also trying to get on cable that
night uh or create a viral video so for
what it's worth i hope that the court
doesn't respond to
some well-meaning uh impulses from the
congress to to push for cameras in the
courtroom but also some some bullying
and there are there are ways that you
can get to a lot of transparency audio
recordings are increasingly released uh
from from the supreme court in timely or
fashion over the past few decades
so for what it's worth i'm glad that you
on the court are making that decision
and i hope it isn't made for you by the
by the congress i want to go back to the
legitimacy of the supreme court
that term has been uh used a few times
over the last three days
do you think the supreme court is
legitimate
i do senator and so
some of the ways that the court has been
derided and called illegitimate by
members of this senate include over the
course of recent days and weeks quote
leans into extreme partisanship
leads into extremism twists the law
threatens basic liberties has been
hijacked by republicans these kinds of
attacks undermine the public's trust in
the court
we need the public
to believe in the legitimacy of its
government including all three branches
so i would ask you um do you agree with
these characterizations of the court
that have been levied in this room over
the last few days
senator i have nothing but respect for
my
former judicial colleagues my current
judicial colleagues and
hopefully my future
judicial colleagues i do believe that we
need legitimacy um i've said that that's
the currency of the court and i look
forward uh if i'm confirmed
to joining the institution so do you
think there could be any opinion that
would be handed down this term that
could undermine the legitimacy of the
court
senator i think the supreme court
makes its determinations and
all of them are precedents and they are
entitled to respect
um i'd like to come back to our
conversation from yesterday you pointed
out a number of times that as both a
district and now a circuit court judge
you were constrained and bound by the
supreme court's holdings
you mentioned a couple of times that you
haven't had a chance to do
much constitutional interpretation for
yourself
i largely agree
with the way you framed most of that for
the lower courts but i think you would
also agree with me that the job of the
supreme court justice is different
than a district court judge and in
certain ways from a circuit judge as
well
when you serve on the supreme court
you'll have to interpret what the
constitution means and based on what you
told us about the constrained role on
the lower courts
lower court decisions would then not be
able to answer how you would approach
the new job you would have on that
highest court
and so that's why i thought our
conversation on judicial philosophy
yesterday was somewhat
helpful i'm not a lawyer but i think you
took a lot of us to law school yesterday
in ways that were helpful and in
particular
you walk walked us through some
different schools of constitutional and
statutory interpretation in ways that i
think we're good for the committee we're
good for the court and we're good for
the public more broadly so i guess i
would ask you um if you could take us to
law school uh one more time
and walk us through some of the
different approaches to substantive due
process and unenumerated rights
what are the different ideas on the
supreme court and in the broader legal
community
thank you senator i am
not
mostly familiar with the
supreme court's precedence in this area
it's
been a while now that the supreme court
has determined
that
the 14th amendment
which
guarantees
due process
includes a substantive component in
addition to
procedure the term due process one would
think is just
about the procedures that the government
has to afford you before it
um
uh
affects your life
liberty or property but the supreme
court has also said
that um
that that
protection extends to certain
personal
individual
rights um that relate to dignity and
autonomy
um
uh that are deeply rooted in our
nation's history and traditions or
implicit
in the concept of ordered liberty
and the kinds of things uh the court
has recognized pursuant to that
line of jurisprudence or things like
marriage
interracial marriage
the access to contraception
a woman's right to terminate her
pregnancy abortion um
pursuant to or subject to the the
framework established in um roe and
casey
um
travel
their uh the child rearing um the
ability to
uh direct your tr your children
those are
some of the rights that have been uh
recognized pursuant to the 14th
uh amendment due due process clause i'm
less familiar with the sort of scholarly
debate outside of
the supreme court's rulings so will
there be new ones in the future
um
senator i am not able to forecast in
every case the supreme court is
looking at a particular set of
circumstances consistent with the
article 3 requirement that the court
look only at cases and controversies so
it would depend on what cases came
before the court
so
i think i think that gets at the the
challenge here that you and i have been
going back and forth on over the course
of a couple of weeks because
um
i i get the modesty points about being
on the district court but it seems
pretty important to understand what the
limits might be
um as a justice and so i think this
morning again you stated that your i
think the quote was that your judicial
philosophy is your methodology
but i think that a judicial philosophy
of some kind
is necessarily an input
into your judicial methodology and into
every justice's actual jurisprudence on
the court and that's why i think it's
important for us to unpack that because
the philosophies that you've outlined
for the committee again i think
yesterday's
back and forth that you and i had on
briar v scalia
is important and you wouldn't claim any
of those philosophies for yourself and
yet i think the philosophies ultimately
instruct judges on the sources and the
tools they consult on how they discern
intent on whether the constitution is
protecting specific limited and defined
principles or more general values and
whether modern values can be used to
infuse our understanding of the
constitution so
again when you narrated a bit of the
debate between justice breyer
i know you've got lots of uh
intellectual inputs in life but you've
credited him as a as a brilliant jurist
and role model before and the scalia
debates
you didn't really tell us who you
thought got the better of the argument
and so i think throughout these two days
you've focused a lot on what the supreme
court has said and i think that is
helpful and important um
but i've been also trying to get at what
you think the limits might be on what um
justice jackson would be constrained by
so i i feel like i believe we still
haven't heard your judicial philosophy
um and i i wish i'd made more progress
with you on that um but what we do know
on a personal note um is that these
committee uh three days have been very
long and i want to thank you and got to
have a nice conversation with your
parents earlier your whole family uh for
what you've
endured and uh for spending time with us
and obviously wish best wishes to you
and your family thank you judge thank
you
just one more minute
thank you senator sass and senator
blumenthal is next
thanks mr chairman good afternoon
good afternoon
jackson uh i know your birthday
september 14th
yes sir you have the
happy coincidence of a birthday with
constance baker motley yes sir uh who
just happens to have been born in new
haven connecticut ah
and uh we're very proud that she is a
daughter of new haven and connecticut
and uh she is one of my heroes as well
as you
know about her
she was the first
black woman appointed to the federal
bench
she is the first black woman to have
argued before
the united states supreme court in fact
her record before the court
was 10 wins and zero losses
she was
very predominantly responsible for brown
versus board of education thurgood
marshall got most of the credit but
she did a lot of the work
probably sounds familiar to you
so why don't you tell us and maybe tell
those folks particularly
women and girls who are watching or
listening
why
you said at the outset of the
hearings here that
she was one of those
whose shoulders you stood upon as you
came here today
thank you senator um
well in addition to the fact
that we share a birthday which i
discovered when i was in law school and
thought what a happy coincidence in
terms of someone who i so admired and
secretly at that point i was thinking
maybe i might
want to be a judge so it was a wonderful
wonderful coincidence
um
i so admired the fact that she was the
first
it's not it's not necessarily easy to be
the first but it
um it is an opportunity to show other
people what is possible
when you're the first it means no one
has ever done it before like you
and there may be
um hundreds thousands of people who
might have wanted that opportunity and
thought
i can't do that because there's no one
there like me
and so being
a trailblazer whether it's um
judge motley or
uh
justice marshall or justice o'connor
being a trailblazer um
is is really inspiring i think and um
and i was always
um
moved by judge motley's experience and
and think it may even be part of why i
moved um in this direction
well it is inspiring and i hope that
your very inspiring story
will make it possible for a lot of
others to
think it not secretly
but say it out loud
and
aspire to it
because it's what this country needs and
fortunately
president biden has recognized it in the
nominees that he's put before us and
we've tried to work with the great
leadership of senator durbin to
confirm
people of real merit the kind of
qualifications
in intellect and character
and depth and warmth that you bring to
us today
i want to talk a little bit about voting
rights
because part of the reason why those
dreams
now are realities is that
more people
have the right to vote at least until
recently
uh in fact there has been
a lot of
sliding about
turning back the clock on voting rights
uh a
gentleman sitting behind you
uh doug jones our former colleague whom
we
very much respect and admire
wrote a tribute to
uh vivian malone jones
who has a
rich story as a civil rights warrior
and who succeeded john lewis as head of
the voter
rights project
and he said in a speech that doug jones
wrote in tribute to her as she was
inducted possumously into the alabama
women's hall of fame
i'm quoting
we can best honor her by acknowledging
that while most doors are unlocked today
they are
still heavy
and so hard to open
for so so many people
in alabama and the rest of the nation
let us commit ourselves
to do our part to open these doors
as wide as possible so that everyone can
take the walk that vivian took
i'm going to ask that
former senator jones
full speech be entered in the record mr
chairman
thank you
the simple fact of the matter is
judge jackson
congress passed the voting rights act in
1965
it
was a source of
real
power
to so many people who got the right to
vote for the first time in practical
terms because it struck down
more than 1 000 discriminatory
election rules proposed by state and
local officials it opened
the ballot box
to millions and millions of americans
and it became regarded as the crown
jewel
of the civil rights movement
and then
just in the last few years the supreme
court has hacked away at it in
an exercise of judicial activism
that has been historic in magnitude
judges supplanting
their views
for
the policy preferences
and
official acts of legislatures
in opinions that were written and joined
by
only conservative justices
these decisions were about as far from
judicial restraint as they could
possibly be not even close
and they rewrote the rules of our most
cherished and most bipartisan
civil rights laws
uh you know the cases
shelby county
brnovich versus
the democratic national committee
in effect
their opinions including justice alito's
decision brnovich
are completely untethered
from the clear
statutory
text
and they impose a series of
so-called guide posts
on section two that create
unreasonably high hurdles to the
exercise of the voting rights
act i hope that
you will bring to the court
that
deliberate careful methodology that you
described earlier very convincingly
it is part of your judicial philosophy
in the sense that it's your approach to
cases
and it has been very persuasively and
clearly articulated
and i think if that kind of
deliberate and careful methodology had
prevailed
on the united states supreme court we
would still have the voting rights act
in full right now
and i hope that
we can once again return to bipartisan
support
of those rights
the most recent exercise of
uh
unfortunate decision making in the
voting rights area came just
hours ago when the supreme court struck
down
the decision of the wisconsin state
supreme court
in wisconsin legislature versus
wisconsin elections commission what is
striking is not only the result
but the fact that it was done as part of
the shadow docket
we've talked a lot about it here
and
what the people of america could should
know is
there's no oral argument
there's only minimal briefing
there are no full opinions of the court
in fact
i'm holding up a per curium
opinion
that is about 12 pages in length
from the court
which means you don't know who wrote it
and
there is a powerful descent i recommend
that
everyone read it
again use of the shadow docket has
become increasingly prevalent since
2017
and in effect the united states supreme
court is shirking its duty i hope you
will bring to the court
the kind of responsible
and
methodical approach to decision making
that will lead to an avoidance of
the shadow docket
as well as a return to
the voting rights act and if i can just
offer one more
piece of advice on
the court's workload
uh
i have um
a chart
uh
i know we're not going by the rules of
evidence here
but uh this chart uh indicates the
um
signed decisions
of the united states supreme court
over
a good part of its history
and
i think
the pattern here is pretty clear
the court
issues fewer sign
opinions
in fact
it has declined
precipitously since 1972
this little blip at the end here
is an increase from 53 to 57
but you can see it's only a fraction of
what the court used to do
in signed opinions even from the time
when i was a law clerk
it's diminished
profoundly
the supreme court needs to do its job
it needs to issue signed opinions not
the shadow docket it needs to take cases
and resolve
real fundamental important issues
and
taking your record
573 opinions
over nine years
i'm not a math major but that's about 64
opinions a year that's a lot more than
they do all nine of them
so
i hope you will bring the energy that
you have
demonstrated in this room the energy
and the work ethic
to
the united states supreme court because
clearly you have both
and i think the court
is very much in need of it as it is some
of the other great qualities intellect
character
that you have demonstrated here
uh
just a couple more points
if i may
um
you were
asked earlier about
dissents
um
i want to ask you about one
in particular
the descent of your mentor
and your
predecessor on the court
justice breyer
um
i am told i think i've read
that there is one opinion that he is
proudest of
could you tell us
what you recall it being
if you know
senator i'm not able to answer that
question
well i think he said
that uh
the dissent that he is proudest of
was in parents involved in community
schools versus seattle school district
i think he said it was the opinion that
he was
proudest of
and he cited it
in a harvard law school symposium about
his notable opinions
and he said this dissent was
most notable
um
i will give you this citation
when we're done
um and asked that it be entered into the
record mr chairman
without objection
uh
it's 77 pages long
and it's a dissent
uh
it's a descent in the
parents-involved case which
was a five-justice plurality in
validating public school
integration plans
in seattle and louisville
the plans had been in place for decades
put in place by two local school boards
voluntarily trying to address
school segregation in public schools in
both of those
cities
and the
justices conservative justice striking
down the school integration plans
said in the fact they couldn't
move forward with those integration
plans
you may recall it is
the
opinion
where
chief justice roberts said
very famously the way to stop
discrimination on the basis of race
is to stop discrimination
stop discriminating on the basis of race
justice breyer
in descent
which reminded me of a lot of what
you've said here
this week
wrote quote
i do not claim to know how best
to stop harmful discrimination how best
to create a society
that includes all americans how best to
overcome
our serious problems of increasing
de facto
segregation
but as a judge
i do know that the constitution does not
authorize judges to dictate solutions to
these problems
rather the constitution creates a
democratic political system
through which the people themselves
through their legislators
must find
must together find answers the court
should leave them to their work
i think that's the philosophy that
you've
articulated here today the judicial
philosophy
of
separate branches of government as you
so eloquently described our
constitutional scheme
our federalism
that really should have
led the court to respect the wisconsin
supreme court's decision and the
wisconsin
governor's decision
and to stay in its lane
as you have
put it so well
the fact is there
has been a lot of progress and we see it
in this
hearing room
but there is a lot of work still to be
done and
there's a lot of reason
for folks to feel
even
some anger at what we've seen on voting
rights
and on
[Music]
re-segregation
some areas
so
i am really
excited
as i've indicated and joyful
at
the
great landmark
and the historic accomplishment that
your nomination represents and reflects
and i hope as i've said that
not only will you make the court look
more like america but hopefully think
more
like america
and i want to thank you for
your
very hard work all of what you
personally
have done because you as a person have
done it
and history has given you this
opportunity your parents
have helped to make it possible
your family story is so powerful
but
you've really earned it
and
we're grateful to you for
providing all of us that role model
thank you mr trump
thank you senator blumenthal senator
holy thank you mr chairman judge good to
see you again good to see you senator we
don't have a lot of time so let me just
get straight into it uh senator cruz was
asking you at the end of of his time and
questionings about united states versus
stewart this is the case where neil
stewart tried to cross state lines to
rape another person's nine-year-old
daughter he had 6 700 images and videos
of egregious and brutal child
pornography the government recommended
97 months the guidelines said 97 to 121
months
you came in at 57 months senator cruz
asked you why the chairman wouldn't let
you let you answer i thought maybe you'd
like to answer now
thank you senator
no one case can stand in for a judge's
entire record
i have
sentenced more than 100 people in a
variety of egregious circumstances
in every case
and especially cases
that involve
the kinds of acts that you're talking
about the kinds of evidence that i had
to deal with as a judge
in every case
i am balancing the factors that congress
has determined are appropriate and
required for a judge to make a
determination
the data points that
senator cruz pointed to that you may
have in front of you
don't account for all of the information
that was before me as a judge
and
the authority
that
you all
congress and your prior confirmation
when i was a district judge provided for
me to exercise
my judgment and i treated those cases in
every case
very seriously
and imposed a sentence that was
sufficient but not greater than
necessary to promote the purposes of
punishment would it surprise you to
learn that mr stewart's a recidivist it
was lawrence issued again for his arrest
just three years after you sentenced him
would it surprise me yeah what is
surprising
you know senator um
there is data in the sentencing
commission and elsewhere that indicates
that there are recidivism
serious recidivism issues
and so among the
various people that i've sentenced i'm
not surprised that there are people who
reoffend and it is a terrible thing that
happens in our system yeah indeed it is
let me ask you about the hawkins case
you know i talked about this yesterday
you've been able to think about it
overnight this is a case where you had
an 18 year old
who possessed and distributed hundreds
of images of eight-year-olds and
nine-year-olds and ten-year-olds and you
gave him frankly a slap on the risens of
three months senator you regret it i
don't remember whether it was um
distribution or possession it was law do
you regret it in in the law
there are different
uh crimes that people committed you gave
them three months my question is do you
regret it or not senator
what
i regret
is that in a hearing
about
my qualifications to
be
a justice on the supreme court we've
spent a lot of time
focusing
on this
small subset of my sentences and i've
tried to explain you regret that we're
focusing on your cases i don't
understand no no no i'm i'm i'm talking
about the fact that you're talking about
child pornography
very serious cases i'm glad we agree on
that
some some of which
some of which involve
conduct that i sentence people to 25 30
years three months in this case judge do
you regret it you haven't answered my
question yet do you regret this sentence
senator i would have to look at the
circumstances
what i'm telling you you you know the
circumstances we discussed it for half
an hour yesterday there's a 55-page
transcript which i'm sure you've read
you lived it as you've emphasized to
this committee over and over you've
lived it right you said that you've been
through all of this you've looked at all
of the images you're the one who's had
to endure all of it
you gave him a three-month sentence i
just wonder if you regret it if you
stand by it i mean do you stand by that
sentence senator in every case
i followed what congress authorized me
to do in looking
to the best of my ability at all of the
various factors
that
apply
that constrain judges that give us
discretion but also tell us how to
sentence
and i ruled in every case
based on all of the relevant factors so
you don't regret it
no one case senator can stand in for i'm
not asking you i'm asking if you regret
this sentence in this case and it sounds
like the answer is no but i want to tell
you i regret it
i regret that you gave him only three
months let me read to you what you said
about these kinds of cases in fact to
this defendant you said make no mistake
mr hawkins the children you saw on those
pictures were not willing participants
in the conduct that you witnessed they
were being forced to commit unspeakable
acts of sexual violence for the pleasure
of the person who was filming and for
the gratification of sick people
everywhere people who apparently have no
shred of empathy for what thus must be
doing to the children who are being
abused in this way you go on some of the
children you saw in those pictures will
never never have an adult a normal adult
relationship
some of them will turn to drugs and
prostitution and other vices to try to
deal emotionally with the pain that
results from the torture that they have
experienced and even those who manage to
lead a somewhat normal adult life
say they live in constant fear of being
recognized
some people are even unable to leave
their houses because once those pictures
are on the internet they are there
forever and the victims can't do
anything without worrying that every
person that they meet has seen them in
their most vulnerable state at the most
horrible time in their lives that's your
words pages 34 and 35 the transcript
powerful words judge i just don't
understand why after saying this and
believing this you could give this guy
three months in prison when the
probation office that we've heard so
much about
recommended 18 months even the probation
office recommended 18 months
do anything to add
no senator
let me ask you about your policy of not
giving enhancements when there are
pre-pubescent children like there were
in the hawkins case who are eight nine
ten years old when there are
prepubescent children involved i don't i
i'm just struggling to understand this
you said it in hawkins you said that you
weren't going to give him an enhancement
you weren't going to give make his
sentence any tougher despite the fact
that we had all of these terrible videos
that you and i talked about at length
yesterday this is page 38 of the
transcript just so we're all following
along you said in your case i don't feel
that it is appropriate necessarily to
increase the penalty on the basis of her
use of a computer we've talked about
that or the number of images or
prepubescent victims as the guidelines
require
because these circumstances exist in
many cases if not most and they don't
signal an especially heinous or
egregious child pornography offense you
said the same thing in the cooper case
just last year this was an individual
cooper who was 30 years old at the time
of his sentencing he pleaded guilty to
distributing child pornography he posted
between three and four dozen images of
child exploitation to tumblr where it
could be accessed publicly
the government said and i'll quote from
the transcript in that case page 37 when
his devices were found including the
computer within the computer and on an
untitled folder were many many many
videos the nature of these videos went
well beyond mere child pornography the
government says i don't mean to make
light of the content of any child
pornography but rather to say that the
content of those videos is on the more
egregious or extreme spectrum of the
child pornography videos that are
encountered in these cases
and yet when you sentenced him
you said i'm quoting now from the
transcript in cooper i'm really
reluctant to get into the nature of the
porn and then later it's very difficult
to assess how different mr cooper's
images are than those of other similarly
situated child pornography dependent
defendants rather such that i without
going into looking at them and i'm not
an expert you say so you say while i
understand the government's arguments mr
miranda the government's arguments in
that regard i don't find them persuasive
from the standpoint of characterizing
this as an especially egregious child
pornography offense help me understand
this judge why is it that you what's
your policy disagreement with the
guidelines treating
images videos
pornographic images that have small
children infants seven eight nine year
olds why won't you give an enhancement
for those help me understand that
thank you senator i'll make two
responses first that's not
my policy disagreement i don't know
why you've characterized that in that
way well wait a minute wait a minute you
say right here in the cases i mean this
is
this is what i want to get i want to
make sure that we're talking about the
same thing here
this in the hawkins case i don't feel
that it's appropriate necessarily to
increase the penalty on the basis of
your use of a computer or the number of
images or prepubescent victims and you
say the same thing in cooper
senator
two
observations one
i am
sentencing in every case i have policy
disagreements with certain aspects of
the operation of the guidelines that i
lay out in every case as congress has
required and as the supreme court
permits
in light of
my experience not only as a district
judge but also on the sentencing
commission which did a report
about the operation of the guidelines
second
you've read
extensively
from
the government's argument in this case
you've not provided information from the
probation office or the defense and when
i don't have the probation officer no
excuse me senator the probation office
provides a
recommendation
there has been information gathered
about what a recommendation was given in
each one of these cases i don't have
that information here but what i'm
saying
is that in every case the judge is not
just hearing from the government the the
judges not just
evaluating what the government says in
these cases in every criminal case
a judge has to take into account
all sorts of factors including arguments
being made
by the defendant
by the government by the probation
office so i understand
that in certain cases the government may
have made an argument but there are
other people in our criminal justice
system who make arguments and the court
evaluates everything as congress has
directed and no one case can stand in
for my entire record of how i deal with
criminal cases or did when i was a
district judge
i have law enforcement in my family i am
a mother who has
daughters
who
took these cases home with me at night
because
they are so graphic
in terms of the kinds of images that you
are describing they give you not only
the actual videos which you can ask to
see but they describe
in the briefs
in detail
what these videos show so i am fully
aware
of the seriousness of this offense and
also my obligation to take into account
all of the various aspects
of the crime as congress has required me
to do and i made a determination
seriously in each case what i'm trying
to understand is why is it that you say
multiple times that just because there
are pre-pubescent victims in cooper in
hawkins that that does not signal that
this is a heinous or egregious child
pornography offense and you're not going
to apply any sentencing enhancements
that the government's asking you for the
sentence gets to be less
because you say i'm not going to apply
the government asked for enhancements
related to prepubescent children related
to the nature of these images you say
i'm not going to apply it but i get what
you're telling me is i guess that you
you don't have a policy objection why
why didn't you apply the enhancements as
they were asked for senator i've
answered this question many times from
many senators who've asked me so i'll
stand on what i've already said
so you have nothing to add about about
why these crimes why these images in
your view
do not signal an especially heinous or
egregious child pornography offense
that's hawkins
you say in cooper i understand the
government's argument but i don't find
them persuasive the fact that there were
pre-predestined children from the
standpoint of characterizing this as an
especially egregious child pornography
offense that's page 58.
let me ask you this you said senator
graham to senator graham earlier today
that you were trying to do what's
rational
and you didn't in sentencing in these
cases and you didn't think it was
rational to sentence people who had
thousands of images
by using a computer
to the sentencing guidelines to the man
to the mandatory range i'm sorry it's
not mandatory to the no longer mandatory
range the discretionary range no senator
i said the guidelines system
is designed to be rational okay so let
me ask you this
why isn't it rational
to sentence people who have thousands of
images
on a computer
to more time
as opposed to somebody who has
one or two pictures
in the mail
in other words the more images there are
why wouldn't you want to sentence that
person to more time rather than less why
isn't that rational
senator i've answered this question and
i'll stand on what i already answered
so
but your answer is what i mean refresh
my memory
senator i've answered this question i've
explained how the guidelines work and
i'll stand on my answer but the
guidelines are not mandatory i wish they
were but they're not the supreme court
made that determination i'm trying to
understand why you think it's rational
not to sentence
criminals based on the number of images
they have you say that this is a policy
disagreement that you have with the
guidelines this gets to the core of your
judicial philosophy
you served on the sentencing commission
where you recommended changes to the
guidelines based in part on this policy
disagreement so i think it's relevant
and indeed vital we understand what the
policy disagreement is that's what i'm
trying to get at senator i've previously
explained what the policy disagreement
is and i will stand on my answer
so you're not going to answer my
question no i've answered your question
in my answer you haven't answered my
question i'm sitting here asking you and
you're declining to answer
i've explained
how
uh the guidelines work i've explained
that
the guidelines were developed at a time
in which the commission of this crime
was different than it is today i've
explained that congress has not
intervened to
revise or direct the commission around
how to deal with the changes in the
commission of this crime and so judges
all over the country are grappling with
uh how to apply this guideline under
these circumstances and there's
an extreme amount of disparity and in
each case
a judge has to look at
all of the factors not just the
guidelines not just what the government
asks for
but the recommendations of the probation
office the arguments of the government
and the defense the nature and
circumstances of the offense the history
and characteristics of the defendant the
need for the sentence imposed to promote
the purposes of punishment which include
things like rehabilitation also in every
case
congress has authorized judges to impose
not only terms of imprisonment which are
a very important part of the
consequences for these crimes but a
range of other
preventative kinds of measures which
courts impose in cases to prevent
these defendants from repeating these
egregious
uh uh
this type of egregious conduct and i
talked uh to each defendant as you have
quoted explaining to them the harms that
their crimes caused and i imposed not
only a term of imprisonment but also all
of the other consequences of the offense
to include
decades of supervision restrictions on
use of a computer and the like
that's my answer i've answered it many
times do you have other questions for me
yeah i do
i do because i wanna i wanna try to
understand when you talk about the
guidelines being outdated and outmoded
i understand that they were
written the initial guidelines were
written at a time when computers were
not common everybody didn't have one
cert didn't have phones and
every pocket like we do now smartphones
so i understand that
i also understand that
the number of images
sexually exploitative images of children
on these devices has exploded and so i'm
trying to get at what senator coons
earlier characterized as a pretty
fundamental policy question which i
think is the correct characterization
here i'm trying to understand your view
on why it is
that while the images the number of
images available on these things has
exploded
that sentencing shouldn't track that you
see what i'm saying i mean you've made
the argument if i understand you right
now i want you to correct me if i'm
wrong you've made the argument that well
look the guidelines were written at a
time when this stuff was like it was it
was an individual picture it was you
know magazines whatever now almost every
offender i i think this is the argument
so you correct me almost every offender
because of the nature of this
they've got tens hundreds sometimes
thousands i mean partly because the
nature of this
my question to you is wouldn't we want
to deter that isn't that a reason to
impose tougher sentences i mean senator
go ahead the the congress has every
ability to do that what's happening now
is that you have a guideline that has
gradations in it
for the number of images
that ends up being when you look at the
scale something like the difference of
10 years i'm making i i don't know
exactly what it is but each
each two level enhancement is like
several years and the gradations are
like
zero to and again i don't have it in
front of me but it's like zero to fifty
pictures 50 to 100 pictures 100 to 150
pictures set up at a time in which the
mail
was the primary mode of possession and
distribution and so if somebody had 50
pictures
they
according to congress and the commission
at the time deserved an extra 10 years
in prison
now with that scale
everybody's at the top
immediately just because of the nature
of the internet so you're not
differentiating using that scale anymore
given the way this crime is committed
and so judges are having to decide how
are we going to deal with the penalties
and
do our jobs to impose sentences that are
sufficient but not greater than
necessary under these circumstances yep
thank you judge i'll just i'll just say
in closing that i appreciate that answer
and i understand that as a policy matter
i just think we disagree i think that
somebody the more images are there the
more punishment there should be and i
want to see this deterred and i just
think we've pretty fundamentally
disagreed i've enjoyed our exchanges
thank you for your candor and uh i
appreciate it i just disagree with you
on the law thank you mr chairman
senator hirono mr chairman
mr chairman senator roano's tired mr
chairman i'm asking you to be recognized
to make a point to the chairman
i believe he recognized me
mr chairman mr chairman i i waited my
turn on here and i've been on this
committee for 47 years i i think we
ought to fall in regular order mr
chairman the witness just said that we
cannot understand those cases without
the three sentences i don't want to go
through this again i have a letter that
i want to enter into the rules that's
signed by ten senators on this committee
do you are you not even going to allow a
letter from ten senators on this
committee any letter you can do it this
letter that is signed by 10 senators on
the committee address to you
makes the point that the white house
gave you probation
information for democrats that was not
provided to the minority on this
committee and just now judge jackson
told senator hawley you cannot
understand these cases without reading
the probation reports
ten senators on this committee are
asking the chairman mr chairman to
provide those reports so we can do what
judge jackson just chairman right which
is to assess those
i know the junior senator from texas
likes to get on television but most of
us have been here a long time trying to
follow the rules
uh
and he could very easily hand you a
letter to go in the record
he's saying he's doing this to help
senator holly senator hawley could put
it in and he didn't but let's get back
to recording senator holly didn't write
the letter mr government i asked him his
consent that it be admitted to the
record senator rono thank you are you
denying consent
thank you mr chairman
aloha judge jackson aloha
i'm going to try and spread some aloha
into this room
i'm taking a lead from
my friend senator uh sitting to my left
well at least you and i are very color
coordinated today
so since 2018 i have been asking every
nominee that comes before the committees
on which i said the two questions
that i asked you at the start of my time
namely
whether or not they have a history of
sexual assault or harassment this is
something i started
in 2018 to make sure that harassment and
abuse
that women mainly have put up with since
as far as i'm concerned time immemorial
didn't continue to get swept under the
rug
i found these questions to be important
for nominees to the judiciary
as chief justice roberts stated in his
2017 year-end report on the federal
judiciary
events in recent months have illuminated
the depth of the problem of sexual
harassment in the workplace and events
in the past few weeks have made clear
that the judicial branch is not immune
here are just a few examples of abusive
practices by federal judges in december
2017 six former law clerks and
staffers accused ninth circuit judge
alex kozinski of subjecting them to a
range of inappropriate sexual conduct
and comments
in september 2019 the 10th circuit
judicial council issued an order finding
that district court judge carlos
apologized if i mispronounced his last
name
and harassed multiple employees over a
period of years
including by subjecting them to sexually
suggestive comments inappropriate text
messages and excessive
non-work related conduct in february
2020 former law clerk to the late 9th
circuit judge stephen reinhardt
accused the judge of a months-long
harassment
campaign
and these are a few of the cases that we
know about there are undoubtedly many
more we don't know about both because of
the power imbalance between federal
judges and their clerks and employees
who often rely on connections and
recommendations to advance in their
careers and because of the lack of legal
recourse available to the judicial
employees
many may not realize this for federal
judicial branch employees are not
protected by the foundational federal
statutes such as title vii
of the civil rights act of 1964 that
prohibit discrimination and retaliation
and that's why i introduced along with
chair durbin and senators white house
and murray the judicial accountability
act
which would ensure the more than 30 000
employees of the federal judiciary have
strong statutory rights and protections
against discrimination
sexual harassment retaliation and other
forms of workplace conduct i know you
can't comment on legislation so i won't
ask you whether you support the judicial
accountability act instead
i'd like to hear what you do
to make sure your chambers
is a safe inclusive place to work
thank you senator um
i as you know have been a judge
now
uh for almost a decade and
um
i take my responsibilities not only
um
to
hear
and
decide cases seriously but also my
responsibility as
um
an employer that i bring law clerks into
my chambers
um i was a law clerk to three wonderful
federal judges who were role models for
me and
um
i try to
act as a role model to my law clerks i
try to bring in people who
um
who
have
the respect of others people who come
with strong recommendations
people who i think will get along with
one another
and certainly people who i think will
get along with me and we create
a little group
a working group
and i think that it's it's worked out
well
and i would uh think that you would make
sure that there are no instances
of inappropriate behavior sexual
harassment from any of your
clerks or employees that's absolutely
correct
during our courtesy meeting i enjoyed
learning more about your background and
family and of the nine sitting justices
of the supreme court only three
justices alito breyer and kagan were
educated in our public school system
and you would as far as i'm concerned
make a welcome addition to the court
from that standpoint as a public school
graduate myself
so public high schools educate people
from all backgrounds and most people go
to public schools most people don't go
and get to go to private schools so your
classmates probably came from different
racial and ethnic backgrounds incomes
social statuses
academic abilities athletic abilities
among others
how if at all has your public school
experience shaped the person you are and
your approach to the law
thank you senator i was
very fortunate to go to
public school in miami florida
i had a wide range of
classmates and it was a wonderful
opportunity to get to know people who
were different
than me
um and
to
learn at the end of the day that they
were not so different
than than i am
um even if they came from different
backgrounds and
i've talked a lot about my debate team
um that was one of the activities that i
engaged in and spent a lot of time
with my
colleagues on the debate team and with
with my wonderful
coach
and you learn how to support each other
how to speak across difference how to
how to communicate
with
different kinds of people and it was it
was a wonderful experience and and as
i've mentioned in in many ways different
than
uh the generation before
who
in florida
were
segregated by law
so i take it that not only did you have
i would say uh
a broad experience of encountering
people from all different walks of life
and backgrounds but there was still
a commonality that you had very much so
and and that is very much exemplified in
your approach to
your work i also talked with you about
the importance of the creative part of
our lives
because i think uh lawyers tend to be a
very left brain and i know that you are
a very uh well-rounded person and so ask
you what what do you do to
uh pay attention to the creative side of
your of your life
thank you for the question um
i
took up not
too long ago but took up
uh the fiber arts as they say um my
mother is an expert
crochet
artist
she
makes beautiful
pieces of all kinds and
i always wanted to do that i always
wanted to and she tried to teach me when
i was younger and it didn't quite turn
out um but
as i um have
gone along in my career and wanting to
have some sort of a creative outlet and
especially in times of of high stress
um i started pining for uh something to
do
to express my creative
side and
um i
bought a book on crochet i talked to my
mom i started making hats and scarves
and then i moved to knitting during one
of my confirmation um hearing uh
scenarios because i needed something to
keep my mind off of
uh keep my mind off of the stress so
i i
i have a basement full of yarn if you if
you'd like to come over
i think that's another way that you're
connecting to the people who really
meant
um mean a lot to you um
the creative outlet is really important
to me because in a changing world i
think it is our ability to be creative
in our approaches
uh and how we think about things that
will enable us to deal with the rapid
changes that
happen every day in these days i view
you as a consensus
builder
and so i know that in your work with the
sentencing commission you
really worked hard to come up with some
95 of the time the in this very diverse
group there was consensus in your
recommendations how important do you
think consensus is on what i
characterized yesterday as a very
ideologically spit slit supreme court
i think consensus is very important
it was
one of the
things that i
most admired about having the
opportunity to to work
for justice breyer as a law clerk to
observe his
um
process
for reaching out to colleagues and
trying to collaborate in his
thought process about the outcomes of
cases and it's something that i tried to
emulate
when i was on the sentencing commission
which as you said is a very diverse
body
and
i saw in that context the importance
of
trying to reach common ground with
respect to your determinations
mr chairman thank you very much uh to um
illustrate the kind of abroad support
that uh this nominee has i would like to
enter into the record
two letters one signed by a thousand
public defenders from all across the
country and another from uh signed by 48
prosecutors from across the country
judge jackson i have very much enjoyed
the privilege of talking with you thank
you mr chairman
and uh it will be my privilege to
support your nomination
thank you senator thank you very much
senator
mr chairman
senator i want a letter here signed by
uh members on my side of the iowa i'd
like to put the record without objection
i'd like to comment i had a chance to
review this letter for the first time
just a minute ago
uh there is
apparently a concern on your side mr
chairman
about whether you have on your side of
the aisle access to all the information
that we have on this side of the aisle
and all the information that's in the
possession of the white house
during a break earlier today i met with
the ranking members senator grassley his
staff
and with white house staff to discuss it
here's my understanding of what has
transpired
last wednesday evening the senator from
missouri
selected a handful of judge jackson's
more than one thousand district court
cases to claim that judge jackson quote
endangers our children close quote
on thursday the next day the white house
contacted judge jackson's chambers to
request the probation office
recommendation in each of the cases
i
underline probation office
that probation office provided a chart
reflecting these recommendations this is
the sum total of what was provided
they shared with the white house from
the chambers
when the senator from missouri continued
to raise questions
and request the probation office's
recommendation in these cases the
probation office provided this chart
reflecting those recommendations which
was shared with the white house when the
senator from missouri continued to raise
questions about judge jackson's
sentencing record my staff asked the
white house for information about the
probation office recommendations these
are just numbers for each one of the
cases that's all that is
the white house in my office didn't have
this information earlier because we
didn't know the senator from missouri
was going to make this claim in the
first place
once the republican side requested the
same information my staff shared it
within minutes
so now your side senator has exactly
what the white house and the democratic
side has the same chart provided by the
probation office
and i might add
that some of this had been published in
the press in washington post and other
places but it consists in each case
of the case number name
the
probation office recommendation for
custody the sentence imposed custody
probation officer recommended
supervision and release and the
supervision and release imposed
all of that information has now been
shared equally
some information on the other side on
the republican side includes
frequent reference to transcripts which
we don't have on this side and the
reason being we didn't anticipate this
objection from the senator from missouri
and request that information
now the letter also goes a step beyond
which i think is a very important
decision for this committee to make
this request for pre-sentence reports
from each of these cases
now these pre-sentence reports are
typically filed under seal
they can contain highly sensitive
personal information
not just about the defendant
but about innocent third parties and
victims
we've spent a lot of time here
reflecting on these terrible crimes
everyone has acknowledged how terrible
they are
and how damaging they can be to the
victims
we have heard story after story and i
don't question a single word that was
spoken
in sympathy for these same victims
i would not want it weighing on my
conscience
that we are turning over these
pre-sentence reports to this committee
for the first time in history
and that information
out of this or because it was released
would somehow compromise or endanger any
victim as a result of it
this information was not requested
before it's never been requested by this
committee
and i think we ought to think long and
hard about whether or not we even
consider going into pre-sentence reports
so i'm going to take this matter up with
our side and i'm sure you will with your
side i have your letter requesting it as
far as this information you have exactly
what we have no more no less in terms of
pre-sentence reports this is a critical
policy question which ought to be
carefully weighed it goes way beyond i'm
sorry senator uh judge jackson it goes
way beyond your nomination and i want to
make certain that we don't take a step
here that endangers the lives or
well-being of innocent people
mr chairman
uh since you just responded to the
letter that i wrote and was submitted on
behalf of of ten senators i will point
out that in judge jack jackson's answer
to senator hawley
she said that he and this committee did
not have sufficient information to
assess her sentencing decisions
because we heard the arguments of the
prosecutors in the transcript but we did
not have the recommendation from the
probation office and what she testified
under oath is you can't understand
why she issued her sentences without
having those probation reports
you are right that there can be
sensitive victim information in those
reports and and everyone on this side
i'm confident
uh would agree to redacting out any
information that that would violate the
privacy
of a victim but judge jackson has told
us it is relevant to understanding those
cases and and that's why 10 of us have
requested we have those reports and
there's explicit statutory authority for
us to do so that is cited uh in the
letter we just submitted senator
i don't know where
other members of your caucus stand on
the basic question of this nomination
they can decide on their own and they
will and they should that is their
responsibility i think i know where
you're headed
and i would just suggest that
we ought to think long and hard my
friends about members of the judiciary
committee
endangering the lives of innocent people
to pursue this line of questioning we
spent two days
15 16 17 18 hours and a large part of it
on this issue
i don't believe these pre-sentencing
reports are going to change anyone's
disposition if they're going to vote on
this issue
and i i do not want it weighing on my
conscience that i gave the green light
to release this information
so that it might endanger the lives of
innocent victims i'm sorry
that's a bridge too far for me
i think the issue before us on
sentencing you each had a chance to hear
plenty of testimony on it
and i believe this should be taken up
with the individual caucuses on both
sides if you wish
but and that to me is it's gone way too
far
way too far
i don't want it on my conscience
mr chairman if i might
so like when i agree with you i've
prosecuted
literally thousands of people
uh
i
would have to go back and say over eight
years i can't
i can't remember the hundreds of
sentencings
i was at where we had
pre-sentence reports
over and over again
there were things in there that were
sensitive
sometimes
reflecting somebody who were putting
their lives on the line
to even give a report
uh
neither the defense counsel
nor as a prosecutor
ever thought those would be made
public
and we assumed the judges
we had judges across the political
uh stripes who
spread them
kept the confidence of that
as a result we knew that the reports
were
thorough
and a judge has the final
say but as a prosecutor i might have a
recommendation
but i never questioned
a judge who might give a different
um
sentence because my
my responsibility was prosecute theirs
was the sentence
senator lee yep i might just uh weigh in
here i i totally understand the concern
that you're describing relative to the
confidential nature of pre-sentence
reports as a prosecutor and as a law
clerk i reviewed those with some
regularity i understand the sensitivity
of them
let me suggest a couple of things first
of all it's not unusual for us as a
committee and as members of the united
states senate to review materials that
would be inappropriate for public
release i don't think one of us is
suggesting that
um
there are means by which we can review
things in a classified environment and
treat them as classified we've done that
with the with with significant success
in this hearing secondly
to the extent that wouldn't provide the
level of comfort necessary we'd also be
happy to review them on a redacted basis
these are things that have become
relevant in our conversations we want to
make sure that we we have the facts but
not one of us wants to endanger anyone
or to to
render public information
that is sensitive in nature there are
abundant ways around that
i would suggest that the information
contained in these reports is
dangerous dangerous to the victims
and to the innocent people who are
mentioned in these reports and
unnecessary at this point
it's never been requested by this
committee
and it's merely a fishing expedition in
dangerous territory
classified settings redacted
versions of the reports
this has never happened in the history
of this committee and i would say
senator
senator i will just tell you
i am not going to be party to turning
over this information and endangering
the life of an innocent person
for a political quest to find more
information we have exhausted this topic
we've gone to it over and over again and
i think that this is a bridge too far
for this committee that's my personal
feeling i take it to senator leigh he
made agree with me and he'll be right
this
nominee has been before this committee
for 18 hours
i don't believe that this information is
going to change anyone's vote
you can decide in your caucus what you
want to do to go forward i've told you
my position i want to proceed if i can i
thank senator the nominee for waiting
for this
colloquy and i turn it over to senator
cotton
judge i want to return to the question
of crime and specifically sentencing
in any of the cases where you've
sentenced an offender below the
guidelines has that offender gone on to
commit another crime
after getting released from prison
thank you senator um
when judge's sentence
they
um
often impose terms of supervised release
and there are times in which when a
person is on supervised release
they
reoffend there are also times when
um when they don't but even after the
period after the period of supervised
release the court doesn't continue to
have any way of uh tracking or knowing
what happens
um because if they were to reoffend it
wouldn't necessarily come back to the
same court or the same judge
so you don't have a factual basis to
know whether or not anyone you've
sentenced below the guidelines has
reoffended in the future
i ha
do i have a factual basis i know that
there are
um people who have reoffended while
unsupervised release i can't uh remember
whether any of them were guideline
sentences below guidelines or above
guideline sentences okay
um i know you've answered a lot of
questions
the last two days about sentences and
sex crimes
i just want to be exact about this in
these cases have you ever sentenced an
offender above the guidelines
recommendation
um
i have to take a look at i know that i
have sentenced
offenders to the guidelines if in the
category of sex crimes in general i know
that i've given 30-year sentences for um
at least one offender almost 30 years
29.5 i've given um
i believe a 12-year sentence for someone
at the agreement of all of the parties
um which was
a sentence that
was
a part of his plea agreement
um
i'm
not remembering the others i understand
you've sent us in a lot of cases i want
to return briefly to the hawkins case
wesley hawkins as a reminder was
convicted of child a child pornography
offense in 2013 the sentencing
guidelines for this offense called for a
sentence of 97 to 121 months
or 8-10 years
the prosecutors asked for 24 months you
sentenced him
to three months
we've heard a lot about
this case
and your three-month sentence
of wesley hawkins
but you got another crack at him
in 2019 judge
in 2019 you sent wesley hawkins
back under conditions of confinement
with the bureau of prisons for six
months
with additional restrictions on his
computer usage
that's twice the amount of time in
custody that you sent us into in 2013.
what did wesley hawkins do in 2019 judge
oh i don't remember
senator i have a lot of
defendants who i've
sentenced
who are on supervision who violate
conditions of supervision
if in our system
someone like mr hawkins especially given
the crime the egregious crime that he
committed was likely on a very long
period of supervision and during that
time he
would likely be
under computer restrictions for 10 20
years or something where he's not
allowed to do
certain things with a computer
and a probation officer is monitoring
they put software on the computers of
individuals who are
who have these kinds of conditions
imposed
and
that restricts their ability to access
certain information on the internet and
so uh it's not uncommon for a probation
officer to
um report
violations of supervised release not
just in this area but across
all crimes and then the court
has to determine
how to handle that and you could in fact
send someone back to jail for
violating conditions of supervised
release that are not themselves criminal
behavior it's just you know the court
says
in their supervision
order
um i'm imposing a 20-year whatever it is
a sentence of supervision and during
this time you're not allowed to
access your computer etc etc so if he
were to do that it wouldn't be
additional criminal behavior but it
would be a violation of my order and
when he comes back
to the court on violation the court has
um
factors that we look at to determine
whether or not to treat that
essentially as
the kind of violation that would require
him to go back to jail judge yesterday
we had an extended conversation of your
sentencing of a man named keith hodges a
fentanyl kingpin that sentencing
occurred in 2018 you had
very
detailed recall of that sentence
to my knowledge that's the only time
anyone's asked you about mr hodge's
sentence you've been asked repeatedly
over the last two days about the hawkins
case it's been in the news as senator
durbin decided for
days on end
this sentencing happened re-sentencing
happened in 2019 and now you're saying
you don't have any recollection of it
let me see if i can refresh your
recollection
this is the order you sign
judge on
april 17 2019
in usav hawkins
and it says that you concur with the
recommendation of the probation office
to return him to residential reentry
facility for 180 days
and to engage in various kinds of commun
computer monitoring
and computer computer monitoring and
search there's your signature over there
judge
you really don't you really don't
remember
senator that is a very very common thing
that judges do i've sentenced over 100
people
and supervised release which is the kind
of post incarceration
condition that judges
ordinarily impose
is something that's done on a standard
form which is what that is i understand
you've done a lot judge but
none of them have been the centerpiece
of your hearing for the last two days do
you really do you really expect this
committee believe that you don't
remember
what happened in this hawkins case when
it came back before you
yes senator i i do expect you to believe
that's my testimony i don't find it
credible judge
it's been in the news for days senator
durbin has cited it being in the news
for days
you've been asked about it probably more
than any other case you've ever had
and
i just don't find it credible
that
you weren't prepared
for that
matter in 2019 you know i think i think
he got caught with child pornography
again and he wouldn't have if he had
been in prison for the eight to ten
years guidelines called for in 2013 when
he first sentenced him
let's turn though to your work for
detainees at guantanamo bay
first off let me just ask
do you think most detainees at
guantanamo bay were mostly terrorists or
mostly
i don't know innocent goat farmers
senator it's impossible for me to answer
that question the people at guantanamo
bay had been
accused by the government of engaging in
terrorist activities and therefore
classified
by the executive branch as
enemy combatants okay do you think it
would america would be
safer or less safe if we released all
the detainees at guantanamo bay
senator
i'm i'm
trying to figure out how to answer that
question um
911 was a terrible attack on our country
and the
executive branch
pursuant to authority that the supreme
court said it had
designated people as enemy combatants
and
um sent them to guantanamo bay the
supreme court also
said that anybody who was so detained
could seek
review of their detention and as a
federal public defender
my
role and responsibility
was to
make arguments
in defense of the constitution and
in service to the court that was trying
to assess
based on the authority given to it by
the supreme court whether or not
people were
adequately classified what the legal
circumstances were how these habeas
petitions were going to be
processed this was a series of
um
a series of legal
challenges in a novel environment that
federal public defenders and lawyers
across the country
were engaged in
helping the court to evaluate so that we
can understand
what the constitution required in this
time of emergency okay so so no opinion
on whether america would be safer or
less safe if we released all the
detainees from guantanamo bay senator
america would be less safe if we don't
have terrorists
out running around
attacking this country absolutely
america would also
be
more safe
in a situation in which
all of our constitutional rights are
protected this is the way our scheme
works this is how
the constitution
that we all love
um
operates it's it's about making sure
that the government is doing what it's
supposed to do
in a time of crisis as justice gorsuch
said the constitution is not suspended
in times of crisis the government still
has to follow the rules and so criminal
defense lawyers make sure
that in times of crisis the government
is following the rules okay let's turn
to the actual cases
how many of these tariffs at guantanamo
bay did you represent
when i was a defender um
four cases were assigned to me in our
office i don't know how many cases came
into the office in total
but um she personally had four
i was assigned to them along with
another
defender who worked on the same cases
she was more senior she did a lot of she
did all of the sort of fact
gathering related to the cases and as an
appellate defender
i worked on the legal argument okay
did you ever represent uh any of the
detainees at guantanamo bay when you
were not a public defender
one of the people who i'd represented
while i was in a federal defender
his case
got
spun off and taken up by
a law firm law firms around the country
were also engaged in this work i'm well
aware of what law firms were doing at
the time yes and
i left the federal public defender's
office i joined a law firm
and
the one of the people that i had
represented
was now at that law firm they had him as
a client that's mr al salwan
alcatani
alcatani was the one was the one
coincidentally both he and you went to
morrison forester yes senator okay
what about mr al salwan
i don't know what happened to mr al-swam
you were listed as counsel for two years
during your time at morrison and
forester
what happens is when you leave
when you leave
from
any place firms or government service
you have to let the court know or their
records
their records reflect where you are in
the system and not so much the case in
terms of your address so you know to go
back to mr alcatani's yes he so he just
coincidentally to small world
went to morrison and forrester at the
same time you did and then you
represented him and you did file
multiple motions on his behalf
so i don't know if it was at the same
time i'm not sure what you did follow
multiple motions for him
2008 2009.
i don't recall whether it was multiple
but he was still at the habeas stage of
the process
um
and i don't know when he came because
the partners who picked up the case were
in los angeles i was in washington dc
they contacted me to say
oh we see on the docket that you had
previously represented him and now
you're with our firm will you assist us
with
um looking at these briefs working on
these briefs there were many lawyers who
were working on
the filings that you're talking about
after you left the public defender's
office
did you continue in your reputation of
the client you had had at the public
defender's office
um i didn't continue my representation
of any client i left the federal public
defender's office and then picked up mr
alcatani
through the circumstances that i talked
about and there were no other clients
that
i represented in that way i say that
sounds like continuation you represented
him at the public defender's office and
then you represented him in private
practice as well
and you're telling us that's the only
person you represented at both the
public defender's office
and in private practice
um yes
so you didn't continue to provide any
kind of pro bono work for murderers or
rapists or anyone else but you did
continue to represent this terrorist at
guantanamo bay
when i got to the firm and they told me
that the case was there and they
recognized that i was at the firm and
had previously worked on the case and by
they i mean the partners
in the firm
they asked me
as a member of the supreme court and
appellate group of the firm which is
where
what was my practice
if i
would help review and work on some of
the briefing that they were submitting
on his behalf given my familiarity with
the case
were you representing him pro bono at
morrison and forrester the firm
represents the firm takes on pro bono
representations which means um that the
person isn't paying
and
let's turn to your amicus briefs uh you
had two briefs in guantanamo cases one
for a think tank one on behalf of a
group of former judges i think as anyone
who's done amicus work no sometimes the
client's account the lawyer sometimes
the lawyers seek out the client
for either of those amicus briefs were
you involved in any way in seeking or
recruiting those clients or suggesting
the idea for an amicus brief in the
first place
no senator
were both of those briefs done on a pro
bono basis
um
yes because the supreme court an
appellate group in a law firm
has paid clients and also has pro bono
clients
and
the briefs that i worked on um
were on the one brief was 20 former
federal judges who wanted to make an
argument in the bhumidian case that was
in the supreme court and one of them
was a partner at my law firm she was a
former federal judge whose idea it was
and she knew the other judges and wanted
our group to work on the brief the other
was
not just one think tank it was the cato
institute the rutherford institute and
the constitution project an
ideologically diverse group of
nonprofits who wanted to make
arguments in
another case that the supreme court had
taken up related to these issues because
all of this was novel and a lot of
issues were being
evaluated by the supreme court regarding
the scope of executive authority during
this time of crisis okay so you've done
pro bono work for on behalf of detainees
at guantanamo bay have you ever done pro
bono work for the victims of terrorism
senator i'm not
aware of any such
cases in um
in my law firm i was
in a group
of lawyers that was often approached to
ask
would you file a brief
for some group and i'm not aware that
any victims of terrorism
uh asked our firm to participate so
we've talked a lot about the people you
represented let's talk a little bit
about the defendants in those cases and
how you characterize them
i'll remind you that those were the
president the secretary of defense and
active duty army officer senator graham
and senator cornyn said that you called
them war criminals you disputed that and
senator durbin is repeatedly denied it
as well uh and i'll concede you didn't
use those exact words you didn't say war
criminals
but you did say in multiple court
filings that they committed acts that
constitute war crimes
i'm sorry but i got to confess i don't
understand the difference between saying
someone is a war criminal and saying
they've committed acts that constitute
war crimes so can you explain that
difference to me yes i will thank you
for the opportunity um
so when you file a habeas petition under
our law
um you can't
file it
um against the united states because of
of sovereign immunity the way our law
works you have to file it against
individual officers in their official
capacity that's
the
way in which you're able to file a
habeas petition so whoever is the
executive at the time becomes the named
party in the brief and a habeas petition
is like a complaint in a civil case it's
making allegations
um to begin
the litigation about the person's
detention right you judge official
capacity personal capacity all that is
just a bunch of procedural gobbledygook
these are the people that you said
committed acts that constitute war
crimes with respect i just don't
understand the difference between
calling someone a war criminal and
saying they committed acts that
constitute war crimes with respect
senator
they were not sued in their individual
capacity we weren't making allegations
about those individuals and in fact over
the course of the
case
the names changed so
later on the habeas petition became
against
president obama because he then became
the executive for the purpose of the
habeas petition i'm well aware that the
name
probably changed from bob gates or from
don rumsfeld to bob gates as well but
they were not the ones in office they
were not the ones who were overseeing
the government when you filed these
suits and you said they committed acts
that constitute war crimes i just don't
i don't understand how you expect this
committee to believe there's a
difference between saying someone's a
war criminal and saying they committed
war crimes thank you for the opportunity
to explain senator one of the
allegations that
um
had been publicly reported with respect
to
the group of people who were in
guantanamo bay was an allegation
concerning the use of torture
and
when you make that allegation you bring
it under laws that themselves constitute
um
crimes of war that's the way in which
the law works so if you if you were in
if you're writing a habeas petition and
you say
um upon information and belief
mr alcatani was tortured
that allegation is made under a law that
says that
there was a war crime that occurred as a
result of that torture and anyone
and you're making that allegation
against the united states but because
you can't sue the united states the
actual petition
is named in the name of whoever is
leading the united states at the time so
later in this the course of this it
moved from
president bush donald rumsfeld to
president obama it didn't it's not about
the individual it's about the allegation
that
um
that mr alcatani
upon information and belief
had been tortured
in the lead up to
his detention
i don't know judge sounds like a debate
about how many terrorists can dance on
the head of the pen to me
thank you senator cotton uh ask
unanimous consent to enter a letter in
the record from nine former national
security officials
uh defending judge jackson's guantanamo
representation the signatories include
former attorney general loretta lynch
department of homeland security
secretary jay johnson and the former
judge advocate general of the united
states navy
senator booker
thank you very much judge after me only
five to go
but sit back for a second because uh i
don't have questions right away i
actually have a number of things i i
just want to say because
this has been uh not a
surprise given the history that we all
know not a surprise but
uh perhaps a little bit of a
disappointment uh some of the things
have been said in in this hearing
uh the way you have dealt with some of
these things
um that's why you are a judge and i am a
politician because you have sat with
grit and grace
and have shown us
just extraordinary
uh demeanor uh during the times where
people were saying things to you that
are actually out of the norm i had to go
up dice uh to ask some of my more senior
colleagues
about that what i feel like is a
dangerous precedent
people are taking a thousand cases
you've been over is that right i'm sorry
i said you wouldn't ask your questions
but just give me some something like
that something like that and from what i
understand is that these cases are often
takes take days weeks sometimes months
right
to
to decide
yeah yes there's a trial sometimes and
that folks are taking any of those cases
and just trying to pick pieces out and
so uh my my colleague senator hawley has
been doing this all into the lead up and
saying things tweeting things that i
think that a lot of us when i was just
trying to get some advice here is this
is what the new standard is going to be
that any judge coming before us
that has ever chosen outside of the
sentencing guidelines below the
sentencing guidelines we're creating
this environment now where i could make
myself the hero
of people who have been victims of some
horrible crime and suddenly put whatever
judge i want on the defensive
by trying to drag out little bits when
they have no context to the case
none of the facts
they're seeking to exploit
the complexities
of a criminal justice system the reason
why we have a third branch of government
i i feel bad that there was a judge
mentioned by name in this hearing that's
from senator hawley's state
what is that judge going to think next
time they they have a complicated sexual
abuse case that comes before them
and they know that they could possibly
be called out if they go below the
sentencing guidelines which i showed you
yesterday in my lack of chart if you
remember i was uncharted
um
but that you are deciding completely in
the norm
70 plus percent in many states or people
are doing just like you did
but i'm a democratic senator
i i i
i've never quoted from this
very well-respected conservative
a periodical this is the national review
very well respected they're not not
necessarily something i agree with all
the time
but here's what the national review this
is the title
senator hawley's disingenuous attack
against judge jackson's record on child
pornography let's just read the first
paragraph
i would oppose
judge
katanji brown jackson because of her
judicial philosophy for the reasons i
outlined last week
i addressed that in a separate post for
now i want to just discuss the claim
by senator josh hawley
that judge jackson is appallingly soft
on child pornography offenders this is
the kicker here the allegations appear
meritless to the point of demagoguery
i
i got letters from
leaders
of victims rights groups
survivors
of assault
all
saying sort of the same thing with the
national review feel proud about
yourself you brought together right and
left in this
in this in this
calling out
of people that will sit up here and try
to pull out from cases
and try to put themselves in a position
where they're the defenders of our
children
to a person who has children
to a person whose family
goes out in streets and defends children
i i mean this is a new new low and
what's especially surprising about this
is it didn't happen last year
you were put on a court that
i'm told is the
considered like the second most powerful
court in our land
and you were passed with bipartisan
support
nobody brought it up then
did they not do their homework
were they lacks did they make a mistake
i wonder as they ask you the question do
you regret i wonder if they regret that
that they didn't bring that out no why
because it was an allegation that is
meritless to the point
of demagoguery
you are
i don't mean this in any way because if
anybody called me average i would
i would be upset but you are
a mainstream judge
your sentencing i've looked at the data
falls in the mainstream on everything
from child sexual assault to all the
other issues that people are trying to
bring up
some of these things are being cast at
you that you called george bush a war
criminal come on that is painful
especially because as you said the brief
change these are names you have to put
in and we were talking about a real
issue that goes to the core of our
values torture
barack obama was named once he was bush
left office
there is an absurdity to this that is
it is almost comical if it was not so
dangerous
because the next time a judge comes
before us on the right or the left that
has a body of work like you do gosh one
of the uh some performance artists on
our side
could pull out
one of the cases where they were below
the sentencing guidelines say for
example it was on something like as
horrific as rape that we all agree is
horrific
and they can suddenly put themselves as
the defense how dare we put someone
who's soft on crime well are you soft on
crime god bless america
i got this great text i've become really
good friends with the folks at the fop
from my negotiations and this was my
favorite text you all got to get this i
think my brother kennedy might get a
kick out of this he goes things that are
uncountable stars in the sky
grains of sand on the beach
and the number of times democrats will
mention that the fop endorsed judge
jackson in this hearing
but let me mention it again
just in case my people say you're rough
on crime folks really want to try to
make that stick
you were endorsed by the largest
organization of rank-and-file police
officers
you were endorsed by the bosses the
largest organization of chiefs of police
and and you were endorsed by noble who i
hope people find out more about that
organization
you got uncles that are officers you got
a brother not just an officer who went
to serve
after 9 11
your family's not soft on terrorism he
went out there to capture
and kill and defend this country from
terrorists
i i i actually sitting back here and
finding this astonishing but then
i i do my homework
i love that my colleague brought up
constance baker motley
you know when when when she was getting
to the floor of the senate
they were trying to stop her with
outrageous accusations you know what the
accusation was back then
she was a communist
dragging up stories trying to throw
anything that they might stick but this
is what you and i know
any one of us senators could yell as
loud as we want that venus
can't return a serve we can yell as loud
as we want that beyonce
can't sing
we can yell as much as we wanted
astronaut may jameson didn't go all that
high
but you know what
they got nothing to prove
as it says in the bible let the work
i've done
speak for me
well you have spoken
you started speaking as a little girl
watching that man right there
try to raise a family and study law
while your mama
supported everybody
you spoke in high school when you
started distinguishing yourself and you
know what you said when they told you
you couldn't go to harvard
watch me
i went to law school i didn't serve on
the law review you did
i didn't clerk at every level of the
federal court you clerked for a supreme
court justice one widely respected on
both sides which really shaped you
you left there and and and you went to
private practice and you know what you
found this is what you told me
that you had those tough choices that
working moms have to make the demands of
a private law firm raising your kids it
just didn't add up
you went before the senate three
times in a bipartisan manner god bless
america we don't do that much stuff
bipartisan around here
you went to became a public defender
because you wanted to understand all
aspects of the law who does that
we live in a society that's very
materialistic sometimes very very
consumeristic you went to did people
become public defenders for the money
no
your family and you speak to service
service service
and i'm telling you right now i'm not
letting anybody in the senate steal my
joy
i told you this at the beginning
i i have i i'm embarrassed
it happened earlier today i just look at
you and i i start getting full of
emotion
i'm jogging this morning
and i'm at the end of the block i live
on
and i get terri because i put my music
on loud when i'm jogging trying to block
out the noise of the heart attack i'm
having
and this woman comes up on me
practically tackles me an
african-american woman
and the look on her eyes she just wanted
to touch me because i think because i'm
sitting so close to you
and tell me what it meant to her to
watch you sitting where you're sitting
and you did not get there
because of some left-wing agenda
he didn't get here because of some dark
money groups
you got here how every black woman in
america who's gotten anywhere
has done
by being
like ginger roger said i did everything
fred astaire did but backwards in heels
and and so i i'm just sitting here
saying nobody's stealing my nobody's
gonna make me angry especially not
people that are called in a conservative
magazine
demagogic
for what they're bringing up that just
doesn't hold water i'm not gonna let my
joy be stolen because i know you and i
we appreciate something that we get that
a lot of my colleagues don't i know tim
scott does
when i first came to this place i was
the fourth black person ever popularly
elected to the united states senate i
still remember
a lot of mixed people white folks black
folks work here but at night when people
are in line to come in to clean this
place
the the percentage of minorities shift a
lot and so i'm walking here first week
i'm here
and somebody who's been here for decades
doing the
urgent work of the senate but the
unglamorous work that goes on no matter
who's in offices the guy comes up to me
and all he wants to say i can tell is
i'm so happy you're here but he comes up
and he can't get the words out and this
man
my elder starts crying
and i just hugged him and he just kept
telling me it is so good to see you here
it's so good to see you here thank you
thank you thank you
i i love my brother tim scott we could
write a dissertation on our
disagreements he gave the best speech on
race i wish i could have given to speak
good of a speech
but talking to the challenges and
indignities that are still faced
and you're
here
i was in the white house with my
democratic colleagues and i'm again i'm
in my joy i can't help it
and and the president's asking our
advice who should we nominate or
whatever
and
i look at kamala and we have a knowing
glance which we've had for years when
she and i used to sit on this end of
this committee at times
and then i try to get out to the
president what it means
what it means
and i want to tell you when i look at
you this is why i get emotional
i'm sorry you're you're you're a person
that is so much more than your race and
gender you're a christian you're a mom
you're you're you're an intellect you're
loved books but for me i'm sorry i i
it's hard for me not to look at you and
not see my mom
not to see my
my cousins one of them who had to come
here and sit behind you
she had to be she had to have your back
i see my ancestors and yours
nobody's gonna steal the joy of that
woman in the street or the calls that
i'm getting or the texts nobody's gonna
steal that joy
you have earned this spot you are worthy
you are a great american
your hero is constant baker motley mine
she is sat on my desk
for my offices that i've held she's my
icon of america her name is harriet
tubman there is a love in this country
that is extraordinary
you admitted it about your parents
they loved this nation even though there
were laws preventing them
from getting together when they were
loving there were laws in this country
that would have prevented you from
marrying your husband it wasn't that
long ago was last generation
but they didn't stop loving this country
even though this country
didn't love them back
and what were the words of your heroes
in mind what did constance baker motley
do
did she this country that she saw
insults and injuries when she came out
of law school law firms weren't even
higher because she was a woman
did she become bitter
did she try to create a revolution no
she used the very constitution of this
nation
she loved it so much she wanted america
to be
america as langston hughes let wrote oh
let america be america again
the land that never has been yet but yet
must be the land where everyone is free
oh yes i say it plain america never was
america to me but i swear this oath
america will be
that is the story of how you got to this
desk
you and i and everyone here generations
of folk who came here
and said america i'm irish you may say
no irish or dogs need to apply but i'm
going to show this country that i can be
free here i can make this country love
me as much as i love it
chinese americans first forced into near
slave labor building our railroads
connecting our country
saw the ugliest of america but they were
going to build their home here and say
america you may not love me yet but i'm
gonna make this nation live up to its
promise and hope
lgbtq americans
from stonewall women to seneca
hidden figures who didn't even get their
play until some hollywood movie finally
talked about them and how they were
critical for us defying gravity all of
these people loved america
and so you faced insults here that were
shocking to me well actually not
shocking
but you are here because of that kind of
love
and nobody's taking this away from me
so you got five more folk to go through
five more of us
and then you can sit back and let us
have all the debates and i'm gonna tell
you it's gonna be a well-charted senate
floor because it's not gonna stop
they're gonna accuse you of this and
that heck in honor of your
person who shares your birthday you
might be called a communist
but don't worry
my sister
don't worry
god has got you
and how do i know that
because you're here
and i know what it's taken for you to
sit in that seat
harry tubman
it's one of my heroes because
the more i read about this person the
more
i mean she was viciously
beaten
her whole life she used to fall into
spells cracked skull
she faced starvation chased by dogs
and when she got to freedom what did she
do did she rest know she went back
again and again and
again the star was the sky was full of
stars
but she found one that was a harbinger
of hope
for better days not just for her
and those people that were enslaved but
a harbinger of hope for this country and
she never gave up on america
she fought in the
led troops in the civil war
she was involved in the suffrage
movement
as i came back from my run
after being near assaulted by a
by someone on the street
i thought about her
and how she looked up she kept looking
up no matter what they did to her she
never stopped looking up
and that star
it was a harbinger of hope
today you're my
star you are my harbinger of hope
this country is getting better and
better and better
and when that final vote
happens
and you ascend onto the
highest court in the land
i'm gonna rejoice
and i'm gonna tell you right now
the greatest country in the world the
united states of america
will be better
because of you
thank you
thank you senator booker we're going to
take a ten minute break thank you and
come back and have the last five
senators ask their questions
everything
oh
hey
you good
[Music]
foreign
yes
all right
now
yeah be in a walk again
lucky
[Music]
oh
excuse me i'm gonna sit here so they can
focus the cameras again
is
[Laughter]
oh
please
he said
it's
is
[Music]
you can just like
um
peace
ah
yes
um
okay
this is
huh
thank you
yeah yeah
oh
foreign
um
um
[Music]
candy
um
okay
uh
okay
now
foreign
okay
oh [ __ ]
sure
uh
okay
now
hello
keep talking
me
so much
[Music]
uh
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
cheers
oh yeah
okay
nice
it uh
[Music]
oh
committee will resume with senator
kennedy of louisiana
thank you mr chairman
judge i want to continue
where we left off yesterday
and try to get if i can get to the
essence
of this tension between judicial power
and judicial restraint
um you have testified
and stopped me if i get this wrong that
judges
should stay in their lane
and i think it's fair to say that one of
your definitions of
staying in your lane is that judges
don't make policy
am i right so far
yes that is correct senator
then how do you explain
or help me understand
the following
we have a judicially created doctrine
with no textual basis either in the
constitution or a statute
called substantive due process
and through substantive due process
our federal courts
let's just
narrow it down the united states supreme
court has given itself the authority
to read into the constitution
unenumerated
unmentioned
rights
not read the constitution and say well
there it is freedom of speech
but these are unmentioned
unenumerated
isn't that ex making policy
senator the supreme court interprets
provisions of the constitution
and
there are provisions of the constitution
that
require interpretation because they
don't
um
just
on the text in every circumstance
answer the question before the court so
due process
what what does that mean
and the supreme court has the words due
process do
appear in the text of the constitution
and the question is
what what is covered by that provision
the supreme court oh sorry i'm just
going to say but when they do it
aren't they making policy
well
senator um
the role of the judiciary is to
interpret the law
to the extent that somebody argues to
the court
that there's been a violation of the due
process clause of the constitution
it is within the role of the court
to determine
what that means whether the person is
correct that
what
happened with respect to their case
violated the due process clause and so
there's
an interpretive function
um that is a part of the judicial
function
here
let me see if i can put a finer point on
this um
it's not the right so much
it's it's how the right is created
so i asked you yesterday whether you
think that unenumerated
these unenumerated unmentioned rights
ought to be decided by the people
through their elected representatives
versus the the federal judiciary
let's take two rights that i talked
about yesterday the right to assisted
suicide
the right of a transgender woman to
participate in women's sports
um
i can see
how i'm not predicting that that it will
but i could see how the court
uh either through
the due process clause
or the ninth amendment
could
find those rights in the constitution
um as we talked about yesterday
uh the supreme court has looks to me
like they've adopted
the the the
the policy of there is no test for a
fundamental right
um
there are several tests
and in
obergefell
justice kennedy cited with approval
uh justice harlan's dissent in uh in po
v allman which says there's no test we
go case by case
and the tip but but i know there are
tests like i'll get the language here
somewhere i've got it i don't want to
look it up but
implicit in the concept of ordered
liberty and you've talked about that
here's a new one that justice kennedy
talked about
in obergefell he said
inherent in the concept of individual
autonomy
well i can see how if the court with
five votes wanted to say
even though the right to assisted
suicide
or the right of a transgender woman to
participate in women's sports
i can see how somebody
you're smart you could write an opinion
and say that's
that's inherent in the concept of
individual autonomy
and and maybe
again it's not the right it's who's
supposed to decide
and that's where the judicial restraint
comes in
i mean don't you think
that the values of ordinary americans
and their ability to side these issues
are just as good as
those of of five members of the supreme
court
thank you senator
there are
um
policy determinations that
are made by vote and
absolutely in the democratic process
people get to decide things
the question and the difficulty
is when you have a constitutional
scheme of government and you have a
constitution that
does protect
certain rights
and it does so in
a circumstance in which th those rights
whatever they are enumerated or or not
are
um
might be things that the people
have disagreed with that's the tension
that um
that although we have democracy as we do
and people vote um and and should
absolutely
um
we also have a constitution that
protects
certain rights against the sort of
majority will about those things
but the rub of course is i agree with
everything you said but the rub is these
are unannounced
unenumerated rights yeah they read into
the constitution yes
um
and what troubles me
not saying i disagree with all the
rights that the supreme court has
created
but i don't think we talk honestly
enough about how those rights
should be adjudicated for example i i'm
not asking you to comment on this i
think you already have but but when uh
president biden announced
your appointment
or at least shortly before he talked
about i want a judge that's
going to read new rights into the
constitution through the ninth amendment
um
and i'm sure some americans are saying
that's a good thing but you got a lot of
americans going hey wait a minute
supreme court isn't elected
uh
a couple years ago
chief of staff ron claim wrote an
opinion piece
and he said he hopes and i'm going to
quote
um
that quote the supreme i hope the
supreme court will intervene whenever
the nation's
and laws need a jolt in a progressive
direction
that's policy nathan do you agree with
that statement
do i agree with the statement that
that's policy making or i'm sorry with
what the chief said
senator that's a political statement
made by someone in the executive branch
um i'm
i'm not going to push it on pushing i
it's not a good time to make the chief
of staff mad is it
well i i i just
i hope you'll keep this in mind judge if
you're confirmed
i mean this is what judicial strength
australia is all about and i think part
of the division in our country
um
america's a big wide open diverse
sometimes dysfunctional but
sometimes imperfect but basically good
country but we we
we have different values that's part of
our diversity
and i think our country works because of
our system of federalism
um the values in louisiana may be
different from the values in maine
and if you don't like what's going on in
maine and you don't you like what's
going on in louisiana you can move
but
as our federal government has gotten
bigger and bigger and bigger and bigger
um what what what we had is what has
developed at least here in washington is
this managerial elite
and i'm when i say the managerial lead i
mean i mean the entrenched politicians i
guess i shouldn't say entrenched because
that's pejorative
but we do have a lot of politicians that
have been here a long time
um
they're members of the media that are
part of the manager elite they're
members of the administrative state
they're academics that are part of it
uh there are a lot of corporate phonies
that are part of it
and many people in this this cable think
they are smarter and more virtuous than
the american people
and that they ought to
set forth
how people should live their lives
people should shut up
and just do what they're told and if
they behave maybe the manager of elite
will let them eat meat occasionally
and i think that's part of the vision in
our country
and i think to some extent
the supreme court
i don't want to say contributes to it
but it needs to be mindful of this
i'll give you another example
and this case bothers me i want you to
explain it
um i think
lindsay talked to you about it but i
don't know that i want to hear you
explain it
it's make the road new york versus
mclegland you remember that one i do
yeah here's the way i read it
congress
we
you know
rare moment of consensus
gave ds dhs the soul and unreviewable
those not my words are in the statute
the soul and unreviewable right to
determine when illegal immigrants
should be removed on an expedited basis
the department of health of
homeland security taking the statute
decided to use its soul and unreviewable
authority or discretion
to state that we're going to have
expedited removal of all illegal
immigrants who've been in the u.s less
than two years
and you said no
and not only that you issued
a universal injunction
and i don't understand why
you talked about judicial activism
and i don't see how clear or congress
could have been
now the d.c circuit reversed you but i'm
i want to hear your reasons
for for issuing that nationwide
injunction
thank you senator for allowing me to uh
address
that decision in that case
the statute at issue
gave
discretion to dhs to determine
the amount of time that a person needed
to have been in the country
between 0 and 24 months
in order to be subject to expedited
removal as opposed to the normal removal
process in the immigration system
the statute said the dhs had soul
discretion meaning no
i interpreted meaning no other
agency
was to have the authority to make that
determination
and the statute said
that dhs's determination in that regard
was unreviewable meaning
it was final once this is how i'm i'm
interpreting um
meaning that once the decision was made
it was over
nobody else gets to review the court
doesn't get to say
no you're wrong if you pick 12 months
for example or 16 months or 24 months as
they did in this case
the statute did not speak to whether
congress intended with that grant of
very
broad discretion
to exclude another statute that congress
has passed
that directs agencies when congress
gives them discretion it the other
statute the apa directs agencies as to
how
they go about making decisions that
congress has given them the authority to
make the apa is a procedural statute it
says to agencies when congress gives you
discretion to make a determination
you have to do so in a way that's not
arbitrary and capricious you have to use
your expertise right in certain kinds of
decisions you have to use notice and
comment in order to get information it's
procedural
the claim that was being made in this
case as i read it and understood it
was not that the agency couldn't
pick 24 months because obviously
congress had said in the statute you can
pick between 0 and 24 months the claim
that was being made
is that the agency picked 24 months
arbitrarily
in violation of congress's direction
about how you go about the htc was
violated yes the claim was an apa
violation so no one was saying that the
statute was violated in the sense that
the agency did something that it
couldn't have done per the statute
picking 24 months they said the apa was
violated because
this is the claim that they were making
sure
because the agency did no analysis the
agency did no expertise the agency did
not evaluate
okay if you've been here six months
these are the kinds of ties that you
have if you've been here 18 months right
the agency didn't do anything
essentially according to the claimants
the agency heard the president say
we're going to now do 24 months when
everybody else all of the other
administrations are at this point
because i've only got two yes i'm sorry
all right
what i hear you saying is tell me if i'm
wrong yes
they they didn't follow the apa in your
opinion which you have to do even though
congress passed the statute well no
because
two things one is the apa under dc
long-standing dc circuit case law is
presumptively
applicable to every situation in which
an agency is exercising its discretion
so that's the first thing it's always
there as a background rule so the dc
circuit has said congress has to be
pretty clear
when
it decides to exclude the apa when it's
saying i'm giving you discretion but you
can do this arbitrarily you can do it
however you want
and in other places in the immigration
statute that sets up expedited removal
congress says we are excluding the apa
we're telling you with respect to this
kind of discretion the apa doesn't apply
okay so here i had these two statutes
and there are canons of statutory
interpretation that says that you should
try to give effect to all of the will of
congress you should try to read statutes
so that they go together in a way if you
have these two directives and there's
also dc circuit case law judge i got to
stop you all right because i'm i got it
and and and let me just say i agree that
the dc circuit reversed me they
disagreed with my interpretation and
that's the way
that our system works
let me ask this last question
this is this is a question about based
on your experience
can we agree
that if
on emphasize if
cocaine is cocaine
that
crack cocaine
is equal in
in its its danger
to pattern cocaine
you're with me
i think so one is not more dangerous
than the other if that's true
[Music]
then
the sentencing rules ought to be the
same
okay
it's a policy matter for congress you
could make them differently if you
wanted
this one i want to ask you yeah based on
your experience you've been on the bench
a decade yes
is crack more cocaine
more dangerous than powder or less or
the same
senator that's a policy determination
that's what policy makers do they look
at the evidence related to these things
and they decide what's more dangerous
what have you seen what should
i have seen evidence
through the sentencing commission that
the two compositions are chemically
uh similar
um so similar as to be indistinguishable
and the commission for very
many years
um as a policy-making body
indicated its view that they should be
equivalent and lobbied congress
concerning that and congress made a
determination about in the policy realm
um making it eighteen to one instead of
a hundred to one which is what it had
previously meant okay thanks mr chairman
thank you senator kennedy and now
senator padilla
mr chairman before i begin
uh i know you're being very mindful of
the clock so i just want to say i have
two initial more substantive questions
and then i think two very brief
questions but are
very important
so i'll get right to it
jackson i am
so
glad that you take some pride
in sharing your family's story
as you should
i know i take pride in sharing mine my
colleagues have heard it but i never get
tired of
reminding folks that i am the proud son
of immigrants
my parents came to united states from
mexico decades ago
and through their
hard work and determination
they raised three of us my sister my
brother and i we all attended and
graduated from college and we've all
found
successful careers in public service
now it's a story
that is shared by hard-working immigrant
families across the country
and over the course of generations
families who work diligently each day
to create a better life and to
contribute to the country
whether it's as farm workers short order
cooks celebrity chefs
software engineers or tech ceos as
school custodians teachers
principals
whether they're documented or
undocumented
people who migrate to this country
seeking asylum
seeking refuge
or a shot at the american dream
all deserve to be treated
with dignity
and humanity
now unfortunately our laws and our
courts
don't always do that
beyond our often cruel and
counterproductive choices that we've
made over the years when it comes to
immigration
policy
the language that we use to speak about
immigrants
can often have dehumanizing effects
for example
in the immigration and nationality act
it's replete with references to quote
unquote aliens
and court opinions written by federal
judges across the country can be found
referring to undocumented persons as
quote illegal
aliens
now i know nasa has put a man on the
moon and there are billionaires
increasingly exploring space
well let's be clear no person
is an alien
and no human being can be illegal
so with that context
i read your immigration related
decisions
on the district court with great
interest
now beyond the substance of your
opinions
which what stood out to me
is that you seem to have tried to avoid
making the same choice
as many of your predecessors and many of
your colleagues
when not quoting
statutes or precedent
your appearance your opinions appear not
to refer to immigrants as
alien or illegal
instead use
terms such as undocumented
and non-citizen
i imagine
i hope that was a conscious choice
the language we use
and the language our courts use to
describe people
whether immigrants
the formerly incarcerated
individuals who identify as
lgbtq
or other historically marginalized
people really matters a great deal our
language matters
it's exactly for that reason that six
years ago
congress passed a bill to remove
derogatory and offensive references to
black americans asian-americans and
native americans from the u.s code and
it's why last year president biden
ordered the customs and border
protection agency and ice to stop
referring to migrants as illegal
immigrants
with all that said
judge jackson do you agree that the
language we used to describe one another
and the language used by the bench
matters
thank you senator
um
[Music]
as i mentioned earlier in this hearing
judges um are
the only branch of government who are
required to
write our opinions to explain
uh our decisions and
i have
long believed in that capacity that our
clarity
and language matters we're explaining
the law to people
and
people
read and understand what the law is what
the rule of law is in this country
through the opinions of
judges
so they do matter language
thank you now i want to discuss with you
an issue of uh law and technology an
issue previously raised by senator
ossoff earlier today and uh i'm excited
to talk to you um
about this topic just as an aside
any day that an mit engineer gets to
question a harvard lawyer it's a good
day
so thank you for indulging
but as you know the supreme court only
hears a tiny fraction of all federal
appeals
that means that the cases that get to
the supreme court are typically either
new questions of law
or very difficult questions of law and i
think the intersection of law and
technology is one where many cases are
both
new and difficult
over the cent over the course of human
history innovation has constantly
disrupted our culture
and our norms
and for the most part with good
intentions
but societal benefits have not always
been the result of innovation
innovations have challenged us to
respond with new means of safeguarding
basic rights
whether in the context of privacy
security
competition
employment just to name a few
and i appreciate that the speed of
innovation will always challenge our
ability to keep the law up to date with
new technologies and their impact
i've grappled with this question as a
city council member as a state senator
as the secretary of state and now as
united states senator
but clearly it's also a challenge for
the courts which often have to decide
cases during that period between
technological progress and the enactment
of new laws that seek to account
for that progress
now new technology
alone has given
rise to
a number of fundamental questions of law
as you mentioned yesterday and earlier
including how the fourth amendment
applies to new context that no founder
could have ever contemplated
and likewise the court has to grapple
with questions like how copyright law
applies to computer code
and in the coming years new technologies
will present new questions
not just in the context of the fourth
amendment
but in areas of communications
energy
transportation
health care
and many others
so if you can take just a minute judge
to
discuss the challenges that courts at
every level
face in addressing cases involving new
and emerging technologies and how you
as a supreme court justice would begin
to prepare for these types of cases
thank you senator
the court does
get cases that involve disputes
that touch on technological innovation
whether it is something like a copyright
a kind of case or a patent kind of case
or
the fourth amendment search and seizure
um new technologies do
intersect with what um
what the law says
in the constitution and in statutes and
at least as far as statutes are
concerned
it's certainly much easier for judges
who are
doing their duty to interpret the law
if congress makes changes that update
the statutes to track
the modern innovations
what happens with
uh constitutional interpretation
is similar to what
i described earlier about cases in which
the court
analogizes back to the time of the
founding concerning the principles
in something like search and seizure
what qualified as a search
uh that violated the constitution
when those words were written and then
uh determines whether that same kind of
violation is at issue with respect to
the top technology today
and the court has done that
with respect to
searches regarding cell phones
police access to gps data
tracking technology that is put on
vehicles
because these disputes do
come up
and so um
so i'll take this opportunity to
encourage congress to help us
um
by
ensuring that new technologies are
addressed in statutes uh
that we interpret you're absolutely
right both judges and uh members of
congress are never done doing more
homework
and learning hopefully
uh
judge on monday which at this point
feels like so long ago
uh i suggested in my opening statement
that uh by the end of these hearings
america would know just how qualified
you are
to serve on the supreme court
and over the course of this hearing
i think the american people have seen
that
and
have gotten to know you as a person
they have heard your family's journey
and uh everything that your nomination
represents
now i also said on monday that your
qualifications bear repeating over and
over again and so judge with your help
i'd like to remind the committee and the
american people once again
just some
of your incredible
credentials
yes or no
after law school did you serve as a law
clerk for a district court
judge a court of appeals judge and a
supreme court justice
i did senator
yes or no did you practice law for more
than 10 years before becoming a judge
yes senator
and did that include time in private
practice and time as a federal public
defender
it did
how many years have you served as a
federal district court judge
i served as a federal district court
judge for i believe eight and a half
years
and circuit since then circuit since
last june and as a district court judge
approximately how many opinions did you
write i think we've covered this before
as a district court judge i believe i
wrote somewhere in the neighborhood of
560.
with a very low rate of uh
having been reversed uh if i've done my
homework correctly look i can go on and
on and don't worry mr chairman i won't
but
judge jackson for two days
here's what i've seen
i've seen a number of my colleagues
trying to engage with you in good faith
on questions about the law
and you've answered them fully
fairly and thoughtfully in every
instance
you're showing yourself
to have
the keem intellect and legal acumen
to serve on the supreme court
now you've also sat here and politely
listened
as some of my colleagues have attempted
to disparage your judgment and character
based on allegations that even
as
senator booker pointed out conservative
commentators have called
meritless to the point of demagoguery
and through that you've shown clearly
that you have the temperament to serve
on the supreme court
now this confirmation hearing has been a
reminder
and
in some ways a new exhibit a
that
for people of color
particularly those who have the audacity
to try to be the first
often have to work twice as hard
to get half the respect
judge jackson i offer that with your
talent and exemplary qualifications on
full display if my colleagues truly
believe
in maintaining the legitimacy of the
supreme court
if they really care about americans
faith in the judicial system
they will see that even if they may
disagree with you on a particular area
of the law
that you're exactly the type of judge
that should serve on the supreme court
you're exactly the type of judge that
should receive bipartisan support not
just from this committee but from the
full senate
and if any senator doesn't
then i hope
they'll think long and hard about what
it says to the country
about the politicians politicization of
the supreme court
that if someone as emily qualified as
judge jackson in all the ways that we've
been discussing
cannot receive
bipartisan support
judge and there's just a couple minutes
left
and i'd like to ask you just one last
question
last friday
in my preparation for these hearings
i took the opportunity to spend some
time
with
a group of students at south san
francisco high school
i went there to speak with them about
this historic supreme court nomination
and to speak
with them about you
we had a great conversation about how
the court's decisions affect the
everyday lives of americans
and about the past and the future of the
supreme court
but as i was speaking with the students
i couldn't help
but be reminded
of my own high school experience
when one of my teachers
discouraged me
from applying to mit
because they didn't want me to be
disappointed
i turned that discouragement into
motivation
judge jackson i know that you too
have been doubted on your way
to the seat that you find yourself in
today
even over the last three days of this
hearing your experience and
qualifications have been called into
question by some
despite your clear lengthy record of
talent
achievement
and accomplishment
so i want to end my time today by asking
you this question
on behalf of the young people i visited
with last friday
in south san
francisco and for the many others across
the country
who are watching
this confirmation hearing today
what would you say judge jackson to all
those young americans the most diverse
generation in our nation's history what
do you say to
some of them who may doubt that they can
one day achieve the same great heights
that you have
thank you senator um
that was very moving
and i appreciate
the opportunity to uh
speak to young people
i appreciate it very much i do it a lot
for the reasons that you have
articulated
i um
i hope to inspire people
to try to follow
this path because i love this country
because i love the law
because i think it is important
that we all invest
in our future
and
the young people are the future and so i
want them to know that they can
do and be
anything
and i'll just say that um
i will tell them
what
uh an anonymous person said to me once i
was walking through
harvard yard my freshman year
as i mentioned i went to
public school and
i didn't know anything about harvard
until um
my debate coach
took me there to enter a speech
competition and i thought this is a
great university it was basically one of
the only ones i'd seen and i
said maybe i'll apply when i'm a senior
but i get there and whoa
so different
i'm from miami florida
boston is very cold
it was
um
it was rough it was different from
anything i'd known there were lots of
students there who were
prep school kids like my husband
who knew all about
knew all about harvard and that was not
not me
and
i think the first semester i was really
homesick i was really questioning
um
do i belong here can i
can i make it in this
environment
and i was walking through the yard in
the evening
and a black woman i did not know
was passing me
on the sidewalk and she looked at me and
i guess she knew
how i was feeling
and she leaned over as we crossed and
said
persevere
i would tell them to persevere
thank you judge jackson you don't have
to hope
i'll tell you right now you do
inspire
you
are
an inspiration
and i will associate
myself
with the
closing words of my colleague and my
brother senator booker
that i too refuse to let anyone
steal my joy
thank you mr chair
thank you senator padilla senator tell
us
thank you mr chair
judge jackson as senator booker was
providing his closing comments i could
only think
uh and they were very powerful that if
you like tiz how much you're going to
like mine on the subject of intellectual
property
but before i do that i know you've uh
you've been spending a lot of time here
do you have much experience in matters
of copyright protection patent
protection
senator i um mentioned earlier that i
did a trademark case yep um not that way
i looked up the menu uh it looks like a
really good menu i think it's a good
restaurant they they they had a lot of
evidence to that effect i haven't done a
lot of uh food or restaurant uh
trademark work but uh when i
came to judiciary uh fortunately the uh
the former chair and the current chair
indulged us and reinstituting the
intellectual property subcommittee and i
love that committee
because you really have to work hard to
be partisan in it and in fact it's not
partisan i worked very well with as the
chair with
senator coons and done very well with
with senator leahy and senator roano and
working together on things that i think
are really important because i think one
of the things that make the our country
great is the founding fathers got it
right on understanding the value of
intellectual property and how
it could catapult us into the innovation
powerhouse that we are today
um so i may ask you a few questions
about it but i'm not going to dig
too deeply i do want to go back
to
maybe getting a suggestion from you i
thought
i told you i don't even pretend to be an
attorney but i am
about 30 years into technology as a
matter of fact i spent two years in
boston at wang laboratories
and and it was no coincidence having
been born and raised in florida that i
moved one september because i couldn't
bear another winner um but uh but i mean
i bet in the the technical field i i was
working on in on ip or internet protocol
before anybody knew what internet
protocol was back in the early 90s and
i do think that we should go away and
understand the threat if you've seen the
multiple
of uh
illicit activities and and for the
purposes of this discussion
um
child pornography now
imagine what it's going to be like
five years from now
um
i was talking with someone in the
hallway uh they're taking a playbook
from drug kingpins
the the creators
and the the aggregators and the
distributors
are using technology i think in some
cases to reach out to people and incent
them
to go to these websites
to infect their computers
to download thousands potentially from a
single click
i think that we have to examine these
criminal enterprises
and put law enforcement resources into
cutting the heads off of these people
figuratively speaking
and one of the ways you do that is to
provide
i think more ways to go about prosecute
more technology
that we need
to cut down the supply but we still have
to deal with the demand and that's
another area where these
criminal organizations and others are
taking advantage
and
you know today if you think about
technology 10 years ago it was a little
odd at least 15 years ago
to see a child i've got two
granddaughters uh one is four years old
one is two years old they're technical
technologically savvy as a matter of
fact i love talking to them on the phone
but even my two-year-old knows how to
deal with the filters to make me look
like i've got the rabbit ears and
everything they're technologically savvy
there's a real danger there that these
uh horrible people and i genuinely
believe that you think
they're horrible people
are going
excuse me they're going to infect
and destroy a lot of lives
and so i don't know is it what the
sentencing commission
how would you
how
and and incidentally this is a toxic
subject
in congress
because if you start talking about
better understanding those most people
are going to run away from it but we do
it at the expense
of destroying a lot of victims likes
so i don't
unless you have ideas off the top of
your head i'm trying to get an idea of
how we can make people understand we
maybe we could even have a discussion to
say that the penalties today are the
floor
to to begin the discussion just to
simply
eliminate people from making this so
toxic that we don't better understand it
and get ahead of it
but
how can we even start having an
intelligent discussion
and a productive discussion
where congress is clearly going to need
to act to do what i think everybody in
this room wants to do
is just erase it from the planet of the
earth or at least make a lot of progress
because quite honestly
it has exponentially grown and there are
exponentially more victims today than
there were even 10 years ago
any ideas
thank you senator i actually don't i
haven't been
working on or looking at or dealing with
sentencing policy for a long time now
um
in my work as a judge we're looking at
individual cases not systems or
crime organizations and policies related
to them yeah well i do i think it's
something that that we should take
seriously and after we cool the
temperatures and and have people have
legitimate concerns about
some of the rulings i think that we have
to clear up some of the complexity and
recognize that congress is a part of the
solution
okay now on the weighty subject of
intellectual property are you familiar
with the copyright preemption uh under
section 301a
um no i haven't worked with you okay
i wouldn't have expected you to
necessarily but
and i won't get into a patent questions
we've got a lot of work
that i think ultimately is going to
require us
getting rid of the shambles of
jurisprudence that we have it's a very
complicated field we've got a lot of
mixed signals and
uh current jurisprudence and uh my
committee's working on that so it may be
something that ultimately works its way
up to you all
if you're confirmed but i'm not going to
take a lot of time particularly because
the hour is late and i tend to yield
back some of my time i do want to go
back because i felt like
this morning when i went through
uh some of my comments i mentioned law
enforcement
i talked about
a couple of your decisions that gave me
pause mainly
excuse me because
you know law enforcement's under attack
law enforcement needs to be held to a
high standard i've been involved in this
for
nearly 22 years making sure that when i
was a town councilman
that we did something audacious and
spend a lot of money in getting our law
enforcement officers in a small town of
only 20 000 people kalia certified
that's a national certification to make
sure that they understand how to
de-escalate
get engaged in the community and
and reduce crime and and it worked
but now we've you know there are some
people that think it's fashionable to
attack the police um
and to defund the police and quite
honestly there's increasing data
that suggests the communities that are
loudest about that are becoming the
least safe so i want to ask you
mentioned several times
i think yesterday and and more today
about your methodology
so if uh is the united states versus
jenkins fresh in your mind or roughly
freshen your mind
a criminal pleaded guilty to assaulting
the law assaulting a law officer
it was his third action
assaulting a law enforcement officer the
government ring recommended 30 months
the defense
recommended 21 months and you decided to
go with an 18-month sentence so i was
trying to does it do you recall
i don't recall i would want to look at
the records and see the probation
office's recommendation as well okay and
and that again is something i wouldn't
have access to so i'm just trying to
figure out what the mitigating
circumstances were and there were other
ones and unless you immediately recall
it i'm not going to ask you to go into
details the other one was united states
versus weeks
uh
similar situation
um there was a 24-month request from the
government
uh uh for the conviction on assaulting
an officer and you gave him 12 months
and uh are you from does that ring a
bell united states versus weeks
i think weeks had a number of different
appearances and there were different
aspects to his case i'd have to look at
the whole
file to recall that uh i i just felt
like the
again because i know that you've
rendered some 100 sentences over
a period of time i wouldn't expect you
but it but it is an area that
we'll submit it as a question for the
record so that maybe you can
refresh your memory and try to get back
on that because it's something that i
for one think that we need to
place a priority on we've got so many
law enforcement agencies across the
country now excuse me that um
we're having a hard time recruiting
people and having a hard time retaining
people a lot of people are retiring
and
um you know i know not every police
officer is an angel i was talking with
somebody in my office in my office who
was talking about
her brother she had a lot of confidence
in him she was here to talk to me about
police reforms and
i actually believe that the vast
majority of police officers like your
brother
and your family
you